Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. For my own part, I would as soon be descended from that heroic little monkey who braved his dreaded enemy in order to save the life of his keeper, or from that old baboon who, descending from the mountains, carried away in triumph his young comrade from a crowd of astonished dogs, as from a savage who delights to torture his enemies, offers up bloody sacrifices,
感谢您收听《历史就是这样》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。就我个人而言，我宁愿是那位为了救饲养员而勇敢面对可怕敌人的英勇小猴子的后代，也不愿是那位从山上下来，从一群惊愕的狗中救出年轻同伴的狒狒的后代，更不愿是那位以折磨敌人为乐、进行血腥祭祀、
practices infanticide without remorse, treats his wives like slaves, knows no decency, and is haunted by the grossest superstitions. So that, Dominic, was Charles Darwin, I think friend of the show. He sounds very miserable in that reading, Tom. Darwin, I think friend of the show. He sounds very miserable in that reading, Tom. God, he sounds very downbeat and hangdog. He's not. He's sticking up for monkeys and for apes. And I should just add that that was in The Descent of Man, which of course is the book in which he famously points out that man too is
毫无悔意地实行杀婴、把妻子当作奴隶、不知廉耻且被最粗俗的迷信所困扰的野蛮人的后代。所以，多米尼克，那是查尔斯·达尔文，我想他是节目的朋友。他在那段朗读中听起来非常痛苦，汤姆。达尔文，我想他是节目的朋友。他在那段朗读中听起来非常痛苦，汤姆。天哪，他听起来非常沮丧和垂头丧气。他不是。他是在为猴子和猿类辩护。我只想补充一点，那是在《人类的由来》中，当然，他在书中著名地指出人类也是
an ape. And so there were lots of cartoons,'t there in the 19th century which portrayed Darwin as either a monkey or an ape. And we should point out, shouldn't we, at the head of this show, which we have titled History's Greatest Monkeys, that we are also bundling apes into the discussion and that monkeys and apes are not the same thing. Well this is
一种猿。因此，19世纪有很多漫画将达尔文描绘成猴子或猿。我们应该指出，不是吗，在我们这期名为《历史上最伟大的猴子》的节目开头，我们也将猿类纳入了讨论范围，而且猴子和猿并不是一回事。嗯，这就是
the thing Tom, this hangs over this whole story. So Sam Brock Jr. said to me before I started that if I introduce it I should say that i was delighted that we were being joined today by a top baboon tom holland but i can't do that joke now but i've done it anyway no sorry but this issue see we've chosen the greatest primates in history most interesting and colorful primates in history but but not man not man tom and also some of my choices i'm not sure they are monkeys because a baboon is a monkey is it a baboon is a monkey no baboon is an ape oh no so you can tell basically monkeys have tails and apes don't yeah and apes have kind of broader chests and they can
问题所在，汤姆，这笼罩着整个故事。所以萨姆·布洛克二世在开始前对我说，如果我介绍它，我应该说我很高兴今天有一位顶级狒狒汤姆·霍兰德加入我们，但我现在不能开那个玩笑了，但我还是开了，抱歉，但这个问题，你看，我们选择了历史上最伟大、最有趣、最丰富多彩的灵长类动物，但不是人类，汤姆，而且我的一些选择，我不确定它们是不是猴子，因为狒狒是猴子，对吧？狒狒是猴子吗？不，狒狒是猿。哦，不，所以你可以分辨出来，基本上猴子有尾巴，而猿没有，是的，而且猿的胸部更宽，它们可以
swing through trees and they tend to be a little bit cleverer okay so obviously humans have broad chests very smart yeah swing through trees yeah all the time and also i mean if you find yourself with a creature that looks like either a monkey or an ape and it's dead you can dissect it and see if it's got an appendix or not and if it has an appendix then it's an ape and if it doesn't then it's a monkey a monkey does not have an appendix. No. Interesting. The rest is primatology. And so a chimpanzee is an ape? It's an ape. Yes.
在树间摆荡，而且它们往往更聪明一点。好吧，显然人类有宽阔的胸部，非常聪明，是的，一直在树间摆荡，是的，而且我的意思是，如果你发现一个看起来像猴子或猿的生物，而且它死了，你可以解剖它，看看它有没有阑尾，如果有阑尾，那它就是猿，如果没有，那它就是猴子，猴子没有阑尾。没有。有趣。剩下的就是灵长类动物学了。所以黑猩猩是猿吗？它是猿。是的。
A lemur, however, is a monkey. Or is that just a lemur? It's got a tail. Right. A macaque? A macaque is a monkey. Yeah. Hold on.
然而，狐猴是猴子。还是说那只是狐猴？它有尾巴。对。猕猴？猕猴是猴子。是的。等等。
Is a lemur? I don't know. Isn't a lemur a lemur? Well, this is the thing. We should have prepared this before we started broadcasting. We're a history podcast. We're not a lemur a lemur? Well, this is the thing. We should have prepared this before we started broadcasting. We're a history podcast. We're not a lemur podcast. So anyway, human beings and monkeys have obviously interacted from the dawn of time, haven't they?
狐猴是吗？我不知道。狐猴不是狐猴吗？嗯，这就是问题所在。我们应该在开始广播之前准备好这个。我们是一个历史播客。我们不是狐猴播客。所以，无论如何，人类和猴子显然从远古时代就开始互动了，不是吗？
And people have always looked into the soul of monkeys and apes and seen themselves looking back. Can you see yourself looking back from a soul? Maybe you can. So lemurs are primates. Oh, you've been looking that up all this time. An order that includes monkeys, apes, and humans. So I don't think they are monkeys. Monkeys, apes, and humans. Buturs are primates oh you've been looking that up all this time an order that includes monkeys apes and humans so I don't think they are monkeys
人们总是注视着猴子和猿的灵魂，并看到它们回望着自己。你能从灵魂中看到自己回望吗？也许你可以。所以狐猴是灵长类动物。哦，你一直在查这个。一个包括猴子、猿和人类的目。所以我认为它们不是猴子。猴子、猿和人类。但狐猴是灵长类动物，哦，你一直在查这个，一个包括猴子、猿和人类的目，所以我认为它们不是猴子
monkeys apes and humans but they are primates you see that thing that you just quoted distinguishes between an ape and a human yeah but a human is an ape
猴子、猿和人类，但它们是灵长类动物。你看，你刚才引用的那个东西区分了猿和人类，是的，但人类就是一种猿。
I know it's so complicated this is why I was never you know zoology it's very complicated we've done some complicated subjects
我知道这太复杂了，这就是为什么我从来没有，你知道，动物学，这非常复杂，我们做过一些复杂的主题
on the rest of this but none is so we've got a whoop or a flange a flange of top historical monkeys and Tom I believe you're going to none as so we've got a whoop or a flange a flange of top historical monkeys and tom i believe you're going to kick us off you've got a brilliant monkey or have you well let's find out so the thing is and i think that this will be true of all the monkeys
在《历史就是这样》中，但没有一个是，所以我们有一群，或者说一堆，一堆顶级历史猴子，汤姆，我相信你要，没有一个是，所以我们有一群，或者说一堆，一堆顶级历史猴子，汤姆，我相信你要，带我们开始，你有一个很棒的猴子吗？或者你有吗？好吧，让我们来看看，所以事情是这样的，我认为这对于我们在本节目中看到的所有猴子
or apes that we're looking at over the course of this show humans have been fascinated by them because they are like us and so therefore even more than dogs or cats or whatever, they can be adopted and kind of given almost human roles. And so I want to begin with, it is a macaque, which we've already mentioned as being a monkey, although it's better known in Europe as a Barbary ape. It's not an ape, but it's that kind of monkey that's indigenous to North Africa, so land of the Berbers. But probably the most famous one is actually not in north africa but in gibraltar so the gibraltar apes and it's said that if they leave then gibraltar will fall but they apparently were not indigenous to gibraltar okay because no classical author mentions them so they brought over by the moors maybe tom yeah maybe but what we do know is that there were macaques to be found in the Roman Empire right the way through. And the most
或猿类都是真实的，人类一直对它们着迷，因为它们像我们，因此，甚至比狗或猫或其他什么动物更甚，它们可以被收养，并被赋予几乎人类的角色。所以我想从猕猴开始，我们已经提到它是猴子，尽管它在欧洲更广为人知的是巴巴里猿。它不是猿，但它是那种原产于北非的猴子，也就是柏柏尔人的土地。但最著名的可能实际上不在北非，而是在直布罗陀，所以直布罗陀猿，据说如果它们离开，直布罗陀就会陷落，但它们显然不是直布罗陀的原住民，好吧，因为没有古典作家提到它们，所以它们可能是摩尔人带来的，汤姆，是的，也许，但我们所知道的是，在整个罗马帝国都能找到猕猴。最
intriguing one, this is my first top monkey. This is a monkey whose remains were uncovered in 2001 in a pass through the Pyrenees. So just inside Spain, but right on the border with France. It's the town of Livia or Iulia Libica, as it was called by the Romans. And this is a grave. It had been dug out and this monkey had been laid to rest in it. It was found near to a great building, great public building dating back to the kind of the heyday of the Roman empire. But this had been repurposed in late antiquity. And there was this monkey, probably they've done tests on it about five and a half years old. So it had died early and its teeth were in a fairly shocking state had very bad dentistry so probably it hadn't died of old age
引人入胜的一个，这是我的第一只顶级猴子。这是一只猴子，它的遗骸于2001年在比利牛斯山脉的一个山口被发现。就在西班牙境内，但就在与法国的边界上。它是利维亚镇或罗马人称之为尤利亚·利比卡的地方。这是一个坟墓。它被挖了出来，这只猴子被安葬在里面。它是在一座伟大的建筑附近被发现的，伟大的公共建筑可以追溯到罗马帝国的鼎盛时期。但这在古典时代晚期被重新利用了。有这只猴子，他们可能对它进行了测试，大约五岁半大。所以它死得很早，它的牙齿状况相当糟糕，牙齿非常不好，所以它可能不是死于衰老
it hadn't had the right diet basically right and it's been dated to the end of the fifth century okay so in the absolute dying days of roman power in the west and it's been buried with various grave goods so food in pots kind of various ornaments but above all military kit so belt buckles okay and various kind of iron plates suggesting that this was armor and belt buckles are particularly associated with barbarian burials because the romans didn't bury people with funerary goods. Right. So the question is... Is he a Visigothic?
基本上它没有得到正确的饮食，对，它被定年为五世纪末，好吧，也就是罗马在西方权力的绝对末日，它被埋葬时带有各种陪葬品，所以罐子里的食物，各种装饰品，但最重要的是军事装备，所以皮带扣，好吧，以及各种铁板，暗示这是盔甲，皮带扣特别与野蛮人的葬礼有关，因为罗马人不把陪葬品和人一起埋葬。对。所以问题是……他是西哥特人吗？
Is this a Roman macaque? Or a Visigothic macaque? So hold on, it's in the Pyrenees. Is it in the Pyrenees? It's in the Pyrenees, yeah. Is that the Vandals, the Visigoths?
这是一只罗马猕猴吗？还是西哥特猕猴？等等，它在比利牛斯山脉。它在比利牛斯山脉吗？它在比利牛斯山脉，是的。那是汪达尔人，西哥特人吗？
It could be either. Yeah. But it's definitely under Roman control. So it's either barbarian kind of foederati, so people employed by the Romans,
可能是其中任何一个。是的。但它肯定在罗马的控制之下。所以它要么是野蛮人的某种“同盟者”，也就是罗马人雇佣的人，
or Romans who, one might say, are aping barbarian style. Very good. Very good, I like it. Back of the net. So, Tom, is the implication of this that the Empire's got a manpower problem? They're recruiting monkeys. The Empire's recruiting macaques.
要么是可能被说成是在模仿野蛮人风格的罗马人。非常好。非常好，我喜欢。球进了。所以，汤姆，这是否暗示帝国有人力问题？他们在招募猴子。帝国在招募猕猴。
Is that what's happening? I think it's obviously a kind of mascot for the regiment. Right, yeah. And clearly much loved. Well, hold on. Those are expensive stuff, right? The belt buckle and all that. I mean. Yeah. Well, I think he's been enrolled in the unit, I would guess. Right. A bit like Wojcik. The bear. The bear who became a corporal in the Polish army in the second world war. Yeah. So I think a little bit like that perhaps. Yeah. So there are other examples of this as well. So the idea of giving macaques, you know, they're treated as pets throughout the history of the Roman Empire. Giving them formal burial is something that you can trace throughout military bases.
这就是正在发生的事情吗？我认为它显然是该团的某种吉祥物。对，是的。而且显然非常受喜爱。好吧，等等。那些是昂贵的东西，对吧？皮带扣什么的。我的意思是。是的。好吧，我想他已经被编入部队了，我猜。对。有点像沃伊泰克。那只熊。在二战中成为波兰军队下士的那只熊。是的。所以我认为也许有点像那样。是的。所以还有其他这样的例子。所以给猕猴，你知道，它们在整个罗马帝国历史上都被当作宠物对待。给它们正式的葬礼是你在军事基地中可以追踪到的事情。
So buried monkeys have been found in forts in Gaul, in Germany. There's even one being found in Yorkshire. So it's an exciting fact. That's nice. Yeah. But they were also kept as pets. So it wasn't necessarily military. So Marshall makes a joke about a guy having an ape that looks like an ape. What kind of ape that was, I don't know. The remains of a baby macaque were found in Pompeii.
所以埋葬的猴子在法国、德国的堡垒中被发现。甚至在约克郡也发现了一只。所以这是一个令人兴奋的事实。那很好。是的。但它们也被当作宠物饲养。所以不一定是军事上的。所以马歇尔开玩笑说一个人有一只看起来像猿的猿。那是什么样的猿，我不知道。在庞贝发现了一只小猕猴的遗骸。
Oh, wow. In Pompeii. So another one was found in an acropolis outside Poitiers. So it's all going on. And I reckon you could make a case that when the empire fell, the ownership of macaques, of Barbary apes, were seen as markers of Romanitas, of kind of Roman class, of the sophistication of the vanished empire. And you can see this in the opposite ends of the empire. So in Britain, quite a lot of macaques have been found in kind of, let's call them dark ages settlements, because we don't know anything about how they got there, what they were doing there. So there's one in Roxeter. Oh, Shropshire.
哦，哇。在庞贝。所以另一只在普瓦捷外的一个卫城被发现。所以一切都在进行中。我认为你可以提出一个理由，当帝国灭亡时，猕猴、巴巴里猿的拥有被视为罗马性、罗马阶级、消失帝国的精致的标志。你可以在帝国的两端看到这一点。所以在大不列颠，在所谓的黑暗时代定居点中发现了相当多的猕猴，因为我们不知道它们是怎么到那里的，它们在那里做什么。所以罗克塞特有一只。哦，什罗普郡。
Abandoned Roman town, very near you. Yes. Again, it's kind of been buried there. And it suggests, I think, that it's a little bit like the wine going to Tintagel, that kind of thing. It's people in Britain, warlords there, wanting to lay claim to a touch of Roman class. But the other example of this, I think, is at the opposite end of the empire in Syria, after the collapse of Roman power there and the takeover by the Arabs and the Umayyads come to power. Muawiyah, the first Umayyad, and then his son, Yazid, who is incredibly unpopular with Muslims today. He has a very bad reputation. So the Shia
废弃的罗马城镇，离你很近。是的。同样，它被埋在那里。这表明，我认为，它有点像运往廷塔杰尔的葡萄酒，那种东西。这是英国的人，那里的军阀，想要宣称拥有一点罗马阶级。但我认为这的另一个例子是在叙利亚帝国的另一端，在罗马权力在那里崩溃以及阿拉伯人和倭马亚王朝掌权之后。穆阿维叶，第一位倭马亚哈里发，然后是他的儿子耶齐德，他在今天的穆斯林中非常不受欢迎。他名声很差。所以什叶派
hate him because he is the guy who kills Hussein, who is the grandson of Muhammad at the Battle of Karbala in Iraq. And Sunni Muslims hate him because he is seen as drunkard. He burns down the Kaaba. He does all kinds of terrible things. And so he's seen as a very bad caliph after the four righteously guided caliphs who kick everything off, according to tradition. And the thing that sums up how bad a caliph Yazid is, is that he has a monkey, a favorite monkey, who he calls Abu Qais. And he would enter him into horse races. Horse races. Yeah, although Abu Qais would ride a donkey.
恨他，因为他是那个在伊拉克卡尔巴拉战役中杀死穆罕默德的孙子侯赛因的人。逊尼派穆斯林恨他，因为他被视为酒鬼。他烧毁了克尔白。他做了各种可怕的事情。所以他被视为继四位正统哈里发之后的一个非常糟糕的哈里发，根据传统，他们开启了一切。总结耶齐德是一个多么糟糕的哈里发的事情是，他有一只猴子，一只他最喜欢的猴子，他称之为阿布·凯斯。他会让他参加赛马。赛马。是的，尽管阿布·凯斯会骑驴。
As a jockey, presumably. As a jockey. So he's riding a donkey and all the other guys are riding horses. Yeah. And when he dies, it's said that Yazid ordered everyone in Syria to mourn him. And again, this thing that the monkey should be given a proper formal burial. So he's kind of wrapped up in a white shroud and laid to rest. And there is a hadith, which is in the great collection of hadiths by Tabiri, where there
大概是作为骑师。作为骑师。所以他骑着驴，而所有其他人都骑着马。是的。当他死时，据说耶齐德命令叙利亚的所有人哀悼他。同样，这只猴子应该得到适当的正式葬礼。所以他被裹在白色的裹尸布里安葬了。有一段圣训，在塔巴里收集的伟大圣训集中，那里
is this ringing statement, cursed be the man who becomes our caliph while keeping as his closest friend, a monkey. so it's less than for all of us that's on my thing i really think there is crikey yes crikey and people who listen to our episode on baghdad may remember that zubaydah the favorite wife of harun al-rashid also had a monkey and so i think it's possible that the reason why Muslim scholars are so hostile to monkeys is perhaps because it has a hint of the Roman about it. Oh, right. Nice.
有这样一句响亮的声明，诅咒那个成为我们哈里发却把猴子当作最亲密朋友的人。所以这对我们所有人来说都是一个教训，这在我的东西里，我真的认为有，天哪，是的，天哪，听过我们关于巴格达那一集的听众可能记得，哈伦·拉希德最宠爱的妻子祖拜达也有一只猴子，所以我认为穆斯林学者对猴子如此敌视的原因可能是因为它带有一点罗马的味道。哦，对。不错。
Yeah. So I don't know. Seems exotic and sort of decadent. Maybe. Is that it? Kind of Caesarist. Yes, exactly. Because the Emmaids were accused again of aping the Caesars, of wanting to be like a Caesar.
是的。所以我不知道。看起来很异国情调，有点颓废。也许。就是这样吗？有点凯撒主义。是的，完全正确。因为倭马亚人再次被指责模仿凯撒，想要像凯撒一样。
Very good, Tom. Very good. You can never employ that pun too much, I think, in this episode. It's the Mojus, isn't it, really? It is the Mojus, exactly. All right. That's good. Monkeys in antiquity. Would you like a more modern monkey? Yeah, I would. Particularly because I know what you've got. So we're both shows our own monkeys, and I thought I'd go in quite big, come out fighting
非常好，汤姆。非常好。我认为在这个节目中，你永远无法过多地使用这个双关语。这是“莫杰斯”，不是吗，真的？这正是“莫杰斯”，完全正确。好吧。那很好。古代的猴子。你想要一只更现代的猴子吗？是的，我想。特别是因为我知道你有什么。所以我们都展示了自己的猴子，我想我应该大张旗鼓地出场，开始战斗
as it were, Tom. So we are in London in the 1820s, and this is the life and career of a monkey called Jacko Macaco. It's an excellent name. And he's a macaque, is he? Well, we're going to come to this, Tom. There's a lot of mysteries about Jacko Macaco, which I think goes to the heart of being a historian, because his story ultimately is one about the unknowability of the past. So to get into his story,
可以说，汤姆。所以我们在1820年代的伦敦，这是一只名叫杰科·马卡科的猴子的生活和职业生涯。这是一个极好的名字。它是猕猴吗？好吧，我们要谈到这一点，汤姆。关于杰科·马卡科有很多谜团，我认为这触及了作为历史学家的核心，因为他的故事最终是关于过去的不可知性。所以要进入他的故事，
we could turn, for example, to Pictures of Sporting Life and Character, 1860 by William Pitt Lennox. And he has a section in this. So in this book, it's all about sort of the days of the Regency and the bull baiting and cock fighting and stuff that went on. And Giacomo Cacco is in this book.
我们可以参考，例如，威廉·皮特·伦诺克斯1860年的《体育生活与性格图片》。他在这一节里有。所以在这本书里，全是关于摄政时代、斗牛、斗鸡之类的事情。而杰科·马卡科就在这本书里。
And William Pitt Lennox says, you know, like a lot of top sportsmen, he started at the bottom and worked his way up. So he fought in the Chick Lane and Tottenham Court Road pits, the fighting pits. Are these quite kind of low grade?
威廉·皮特·伦诺克斯说，你知道，像许多顶级运动员一样，他从底层做起，一路向上。所以他在奇克巷和托特纳姆法院路的斗兽场战斗，那些斗兽场。这些是相当低级的吗？
This is sort of National League, Vanarama League, or whatever it's called. There he was known as the Hoxton Ape. And then he fought his way up and he was finally sold to the Real Madrid or the Wolverhampton Wanderers,
这有点像全国联赛，万拉马联赛，或者不管它叫什么。在那里他被称为霍克斯顿猿。然后他一路战斗，最后被卖给了皇家马德里或伍尔弗汉普顿流浪者，
a fight sort of entrepreneurs, who was a guy called Charles Aistrop, who ran the Westminster Pit, which I will explain in due course. And this is the kind of the Molyneux of... Exactly so, Tom. Now, Charles Aistrop actually told a different story himself. So this is the unknowability of the past. Charles Aistrop said that Jacko had once belonged to a sailor and they'd had a fight, Jacko and the sailor, about a saucer of milk.
一个战斗企业家，是一个叫查尔斯·艾斯特罗普的人，他经营着威斯敏斯特斗兽场，我将在适当的时候解释。这就是……的莫利纽克斯。完全正确，汤姆。现在，查尔斯·艾斯特罗普实际上自己讲了一个不同的故事。所以这就是过去的不可知性。查尔斯·艾斯特罗普说，杰科曾经属于一个水手，他们打过一架，杰科和水手，为了牛奶碟。
Jacko had bitten off three of the sailor's fingers. The sailor sold him to a silversmith from Hoxton called Carter. Under fool's pretence, he said he was very meek and mild. Carter had to buy himself a sheet of iron to use as a shield when he approached Jacko, because jacko was so fierce and eventually he tired of being attacked by his own pet he took him to a field and set a dog on him to try and get rid of him but jacko defeated the dog that's the obvious way to get rid of a monkey isn't it and a second dog that is so regency and so carter thought aha and so he sold him to the westminster
杰科咬掉了水手的三根手指。水手把他卖给了一个叫卡特的霍克斯顿银匠。在愚蠢的伪装下，他说他非常温顺。卡特不得不给自己买了一块铁板作为盾牌，当他接近杰科时，因为杰科太凶猛了，最终他厌倦了被自己的宠物攻击，他把他带到田野里，放了一只狗去咬他，试图摆脱他，但杰科打败了那只狗，那是摆脱猴子的显而易见的方法，不是吗？还有第二只狗，这太摄政时代了，所以卡特想，啊哈，于是他把他卖给了威斯敏斯特
pit now just before we get onto the westminster pit a quick reflection about jacko and his his name and his appearance so his name gonna be a lot of jackos and jacks in this podcast i have to say i think i've got about six of them and i've got one the sense is that this is probably a generic name at the time first of all jacko specifically was probably a generic name for a lemur. So lemurs were called Jakko. But also there's a slight sense of he's come from the sea, and people from the sea, of course, were called Jaktars. And as for Makako, Makako was a generic name at the time applied particularly to macaques, but also to monkeys more broadly. Cockneys in the east end of London would call any monkey Makorka.
斗兽场。现在，在我们进入威斯敏斯特斗兽场之前，先快速反思一下杰科和他的名字以及外表。所以他的名字，在这个播客里会有很多杰科和杰克，我必须说，我想我有大约六个，我有一个感觉，这在当时可能是一个通用的名字。首先，杰科特别可能是一个狐猴的通用名称。所以狐猴被称为杰科。但也有点他来自大海的感觉，而来自大海的人，当然，被称为杰克塔。至于马卡科，马卡科在当时是一个通用名称，特别适用于猕猴，但也更广泛地适用于猴子。伦敦东区的伦敦佬会把任何猴子都叫马科卡。
Indeed, there's some evidence that Jacko Macaco may actually just be a generic name that you'd call any monkey Jacko Macaco but it wasn't that he became so famous that we don't know
事实上，有一些证据表明杰科·马卡科实际上可能只是一个通用名称，你会把任何猴子都叫杰科·马卡科，但并不是他变得如此出名，以至于我们不知道
we just don't know this is the unknowability isn't it it's the unknowability exactly but do we know what he is is he a macaque well some people say a baboon some people say a mandrill
我们只是不知道，这就是不可知性，不是吗？这正是不可知性。但我们知道他是什么吗？他是猕猴吗？好吧，有些人说是狒狒，有些人说是山魈。
or a gibbon a mandrill but presumably not gibbon with a mandrill. But presumably not a bonobo. No, because they're very peaceful. Yeah. He was so well known. He was the Cristiano Ronaldo of his day. So he's so well known that there are etchings of him in the British Museum.
或者是长臂猿、山魈，但大概不是长臂猿配山魈。大概也不是倭黑猩猩。不，因为它们非常温顺。是的。他当时非常出名。他就是那个时代的克里斯蒂亚诺·罗纳尔多。他名气大到大英博物馆里都有他的蚀刻画。
There's one by Thomas Landseer, which shows him with a muzzle and pointed ears. And people think that therefore he's probably a rhesus macaque. Anyway, so he's gone to the Westminster Pit. Now, to give you a sense of the Westminster Pit, it's very near the palace of westminster in london so it has the parliament it was at its peak of popularity when hundreds if not thousands of people would come to watch these bouts in the 1820s it would have badger baiting monkey baiting bull baiting its biggest star was as that's a chap he's actually a dog called Billy Billy was famous
其中一幅是托马斯·兰西尔画的，画中他戴着口套，耳朵尖尖的。人们因此认为他很可能是一只恒河猴。总之，他被带到了威斯敏斯特斗兽场。为了让你了解一下威斯敏斯特斗兽场，它离伦敦威斯敏斯特宫非常近，所以就在议会旁边。在19世纪20年代，它的人气达到了顶峰，成百上千的人会来看这些比赛。那里有獾斗、猴斗、牛斗，它最大的明星是一只狗，名叫比利。比利非常出名，
for killing rats Tom in October 1822 he killed 100 rats in 6 minutes and 25 seconds 100 rats wow think of that
以杀老鼠闻名。汤姆，1822年10月，他在6分25秒内杀死了100只老鼠。100只老鼠，哇，想想看。
goodness so what do they just kind of keep rats in cages and let them out well there was controversy some people said actually a lot of the rats had been poisoned beforehand
天哪，他们是把老鼠关在笼子里然后放出来吗？嗯，当时有争议，有些人说其实很多老鼠在比赛前就已经被毒死了。
because of course there's huge amounts of money changing hands and all this. Of course, of course. Yeah. So betting syndicates and things. It's betting syndicates. So Jacko is going into this very high pressure environment. When he is billed, when people say they've got the Hoxton Ape, big star, rising star, better than Billy, quite a lot of the sort of the swells, know dandies and people would come to watch so bigger and bigger money there are adverts preserved from the time this one here jacko was open to challenges from any dog in england for 100 guineas so he's taking on dogs does he take on the dog he's killed all the rats no i don't think he does that's a different class differently yeah
因为当然有巨额资金在其中流转。当然，当然。是的。所以是博彩集团之类的。是博彩集团。所以杰科要进入这个压力巨大的环境。当他被宣传时，当人们说他们有“霍克斯顿猿”，大明星，冉冉升起的新星，比比利还厉害，很多那种阔佬、花花公子之类的人都会来看，所以赌注越来越大。当时保留下来的广告中，这一张写着杰科接受英格兰任何一只狗的挑战，赌注是100几尼。所以他在挑战狗，他会去挑战那只杀过所有老鼠的狗吗？不，我不认为他会那样做，那是不同级别的，对吧。
differently no but he will take on dogs twice his weight. So Jacko is about 12 pounds in weight. That's about five and a half kilograms. And he will fight a dog of up to double that. Now we know about his style because Lennox describes it in his book. His mode of attack, he says, was first to present his back or neck to the dog and to shift and tumble about until he could lay hold on the arm or chest when he ascended to the windpipe, clawing and biting away, which usually occupied him
不同级别，不，但他会挑战体重两倍于他的狗。杰科体重约12磅，也就是大约5.5公斤。他会和体重两倍于他的狗打架。我们了解他的风格是因为伦诺克斯在他的书中做了描述。他说，他的攻击方式是先向狗展示他的背部或颈部，然后翻滚移动，直到他能抓住狗的前肢或胸部，接着他会爬到气管处，又抓又咬，这通常需要他
for a minute and a half and it said after every bout the monkey exhibited a frightful appearance being deluged with blood but it was that of his opponent alone
花上一分半钟。据说每次比赛后，这只猴子看起来都很可怕，浑身是血，但那只是他对手的血。
so he's got a he's got a good ring record we think he overcame 14 different opponents and his advert that advert that I quoted says of him he has fought
所以他的战绩不错，我们认为他击败了14个不同的对手。我引用的那则广告说他曾与
some of the best dogs of the day including his combat with the wonderful bitch Puss of Tea Cribs His advert, that advert that I quoted, says of him, he has fought some of the best dogs of the day, including his combat with the wonderful bitch Puss of Tea Cribs and the famed Oxford One. We don't know who the famed Oxford One is. Now, there is a suspicion of foul play that hangs over this. There's a splendid fellow called George Charles Grantley Fitzharding Barkley. He sounds a swell.
当时一些最好的狗交手，包括他与蒂·克里布（Tea Cribs）那只出色的母狗“普斯”（Puss）的对决。我引用的那则广告说他曾与当时一些最好的狗交手，包括他与蒂·克里布那只出色的母狗“普斯”以及著名的“牛津一号”的对决。我们不知道“牛津一号”是谁。现在，这件事上笼罩着一种作弊的嫌疑。有一个叫乔治·查尔斯·格兰特利·菲茨哈丁·巴克利的了不起的家伙。他听起来是个阔佬。
He was a Whig MP. Tell him, he was a Whig. And a great enthusiast for sport. He wrote a memoir and he says in his memoir, I believe that the dogs were injured first. Right. Again, to rig the matches. Because the spectacle of a monkey killing a dog would be more dramatic and interesting to people.
他是一位辉格党议员。告诉他，他是个辉格党人。而且是一位伟大的体育爱好者。他写了一本回忆录，他在回忆录中说，我相信这些狗事先受了伤。没错。同样是为了操纵比赛。因为猴子杀死狗的场面会更具戏剧性和吸引力。
Right. And a lot of analysts, top analysts said a monkey cannot kill a dog. A macaque will not defeat a top quality dog. This is rigged. And so entire fortunes are being lost as a result. Correct. So the most famous bout is the one that I alluded to there. It's the bout against Puss, who was owned by Tom Cribb. And he's confusingly a dog. Puss is confusingly a dog. And I've actually, I have to apologize to some people because I was telling people about this last week and I had only scanned the reading so I thought Puss was a cat. So I've been telling people publicly
没错。很多分析家，顶级分析家说猴子不可能杀死狗。猕猴不会打败顶级的狗。这是操纵的。结果导致了整个财富的损失。没错。所以最著名的比赛就是我刚才提到的那场。那是对阵普斯的比赛，普斯是汤姆·克里布的狗。令人困惑的是，普斯是一只狗。普斯令人困惑地是一只狗。我实际上必须向一些人道歉，因为我上周告诉人们这件事时，我只粗略地看了读物，所以我以为普斯是一只猫。所以我一直在公开告诉人们
that Jack O'Macaco had a climactic bout against a cat. Not the case. Well, I think there's a lesson there for any young historians listening to this. Yes, read your sources properly. Don't go public with your research until you've properly... No, exactly. So Puss belonged
杰科·马卡科（Jack O'Macaco）与一只猫进行了一场巅峰对决。事实并非如此。嗯，我想这对任何听这个节目的年轻历史学家来说都是一个教训。是的，要好好阅读你的资料。在没有充分准备好之前，不要公开你的研究……不，确实如此。所以普斯属于
to a guy called tom crib who was himself a remarkable person he was the all england boxing champion and he was the fellow tom who defeated tom molyneux in oxfordshire in 35 rounds in 1810 the famous fight held in the middle of nowhere against a former american slave was that in hapshire i thought it was in haps, wasn't it? Shennington Hollow. I think there are multiple such fights, to be honest with you. So Puss, he belonged to Tom Cribb anyway, who's this retired sporting star himself.
一个叫汤姆·克里布的人，他本人也是个了不起的人，他是全英拳击冠军，就是那个在1810年牛津郡的35回合比赛中击败汤姆·莫利纽的汤姆。那场著名的比赛是在荒郊野外举行的，对手是一位前美国奴隶。那是在汉普郡吗？我以为是在汉普郡，不是吗？谢宁顿谷。说实话，我认为有多次这样的比赛。所以普斯，他反正属于汤姆·克里布，他自己也是一位退役的体育明星。
Was he now running a pub or something? Exactly. Now Puss is a dog that doesn't exist anymore. He's not a bull terrier. He's a bull and terrier, which is a slightly different thing. And their great fight seems to have happened in June 1821. There was £50 at stake.
他当时是在经营酒吧还是什么的吗？没错。现在普斯是一只已经不存在的品种的狗。他不是斗牛梗。他是斗牛和梗犬的杂交，这稍微有点不同。他们那场伟大的战斗似乎发生在1821年6月。赌注是50英镑。
A lot of money, actually, in the early 1820s. Yeah, fortune. And our account comes from a guy who was the MP for Galway called Richard Martin, who was an old Horavian, an abolitionist, and a notorious do-gooder. But Horavians love torturing animals, don't they? Because that's what they did instead of playing sport. They go and torture cats. At school, they went around beating cats to death.
在19世纪20年代，这确实是一大笔钱。是的，一笔财富。我们的记录来自一位名叫理查德·马丁的戈尔韦议员，他是一位老霍拉维亚人，一位废奴主义者，也是一位臭名昭著的慈善家。但霍拉维亚人喜欢虐待动物，不是吗？因为那是他们不参加体育运动时做的事情。他们去虐待猫。在学校里，他们到处把猫打死。
Yeah. But obviously this Richard Martin has been deeply affected by this because he becomes, as part of being MP for Galway, he's a passionate campaigner against cruelty to animals. He campaigned particularly against bull baiting and cock fighting, so much so that George IV nicknamed him Humanity Dick. Now, he makes reference to this great fight in the House of Commons a year later.
是的。但显然这位理查德·马丁深受此事影响，因为作为戈尔韦的议员，他成为了反对虐待动物的积极倡导者。他特别反对斗牛和斗鸡，以至于乔治四世给他起了个绰号叫“仁慈的迪克”。现在，他在一年后在下议院提到了这场伟大的战斗。
He's introducing a prevention of cruelty to animals bill, and he says the Jacko Macaco Puss Fight is the nadir of British cruelty to animals and he says the fight lasted for half an hour the dog had its carotid artery
他当时正在提出一项防止虐待动物法案，他说杰科·马卡科与普斯的战斗是英国虐待动物史上的最低点，他说这场战斗持续了半小时，那只狗的颈动脉
severed bleeding and Jacko's jaw was torn off oh god and he lingered for two more hours and then died
被切断了，流血不止，杰科的下巴也被扯掉了。天哪，他挣扎了两个小时后就死了。
very sad now the guy who owned the Westminster pit went ballistic when he heard this he said this was an absolute lie he said actually Jacko defeated puss in two and a half minutes and Now, the guy who owned the Westminster pit went ballistic when he heard this. He said this was an absolute lie.
真可怜。现在，威斯敏斯特斗兽场的老板听到这个消息后暴跳如雷，他说这完全是谎言。他说，实际上杰科在两分半钟内就击败了普斯，而且现在，威斯敏斯特斗兽场的老板听到这个消息后暴跳如雷。他说这完全是谎言。
He said, actually, Jacko defeated Puss in two and a half minutes, didn't kill Puss. Puss was defeated, but lived to tell the tale. And that Jacko actually died 15 months later of an unrelated illness. And Mr. Aistrop from the Westminster pit said, listen, I've had Jacko stuffed. He is on the mantelpiece of a Mr. Shaw of Mitcham Common. And this would not be possible if his jaw had been ripped off. I mean, that's something that it would be nice to see, wouldn't it?
他说，实际上杰科在两分半钟内就击败了普斯，并没有杀死普斯。普斯被打败了，但活了下来，讲述了这个故事。而且杰科实际上是在15个月后死于一种无关的疾病。威斯敏斯特斗兽场的艾斯特罗普先生说，听着，我已经把杰科做成了标本。他就在米查姆公地肖先生的壁炉架上。如果他的下巴被扯掉了，这根本不可能。我的意思是，那是一个如果能看到会很不错的东西，不是吗？
Is famous stars being stuffed after their death. And donated to the grounds that they adorned. Yeah. I would love to see that, Tom. Wouldn't you like that? Would you like to see Jack Grealish at Villa Park? We'd all love to see Grealish back at Villa Park. Yes.
著名的明星死后被做成标本。并捐赠给他们曾经装饰过的地方。是的。汤姆，我很想看看那个。你不想吗？你想在维拉公园看到杰克·格拉利什吗？我们都想看到格拉利什回到维拉公园。是的。
Yes. But a stuffed zombie. Yeah. Well, Ian Botham, of course, whose nickname was Guy the Gorilla. Right. You'd like to see him stuffed and put up in Taunton. Definitely. So anyway, that is the story of Jack O'Macaco.
是的。但一个填充的僵尸。嗯，伊恩·博瑟姆，当然，他的绰号是“大猩猩盖伊”。没错。你想看到他被做成标本放在汤顿吗？绝对想。所以总之，这就是杰科·马卡科的故事。
And we don't have much insight into his inner life, I think it's fair to say, Tom. But I think he's a lovely window into the sporting world of George IV England. Yeah. I think in the episode we did on public schools, we talked about how organisations were set up to stop cruelty to animals before cruelty to children. Yeah. And I have to say that hearing that, you can kind of see why. Well, Humanity Dick was an absolutely key figure in setting up the Society for the Protection of Cruelty to Animals, later the Royal Society, but not at the time because George IV thought this was... George IV was contemptuous. He thought it was wokery. He thought it was madness.
我想说，汤姆，我们对他内心的生活了解不多。但我认为他是了解乔治四世时代英国体育世界的一个很好的窗口。是的。我想在我们做的关于公立学校的那一集里，我们谈到了在保护儿童之前，人们是如何建立组织来停止虐待动物的。是的。我不得不说，听到这些，你就能明白为什么了。嗯，“仁慈的迪克”是建立防止虐待动物协会（后来成为皇家协会）的关键人物，但当时不是，因为乔治四世认为这……乔治四世对此表示蔑视。他认为这是“觉醒文化”。他认为这简直是疯了。
Woke tosh. Total woke tosh. Who wouldn't want to see a dog killing a hundred rats? Well, I'm a big fan of Humanity Dick. Okay. Bless him. So is that it? Is that Jack and Macaco? That's the story of Jack and Macaco. And I think the lesson, Tom, is the mysteriousness of the past. Because we just don't know where he came from, what kind of monkey he was, if he was indeed a monkey. How he died. How he died.
觉醒派的废话。完全是觉醒派的废话。谁不想看一只狗杀死一百只老鼠呢？嗯，我是“仁慈的迪克”的忠实粉丝。好吧。保佑他。所以就是这样吗？这就是杰科·马卡科？这就是杰科·马卡科的故事。我想教训是，汤姆，过去是神秘的。因为我们根本不知道他从哪里来，他是什么种类的猴子，如果他真的是猴子的话。他是怎么死的。他是怎么死的。
I mean, there were even that guy with six names who was the son of the Earl of Barclay. He said the fight with Puss was a complete con. In his memoirs, he says, I was looking very closely. And before the fight began tom crib the former boxer was cradling puss's head in a mysterious way oh yeah and i believe he cut puss before it started to make the bout last longer and maybe to win a little bit of money yeah and so on and so forth our executive producer jack davenport used to work as a sports journalist wasn't he yeah he worked in the boxing world.
我的意思是，甚至那个有六个名字的巴克利伯爵的儿子也说，与普斯的战斗完全是一场骗局。他在回忆录中说，我当时看得非常仔细。在战斗开始前，前拳击手汤姆·克里布正以一种神秘的方式抱着普斯的头。哦，是的，我相信他在比赛开始前就割伤了普斯，为了让比赛持续更久，也许是为了赢点钱，等等等等。我们的执行制片人杰克·达文波特以前做过体育记者，不是吗？是的，他在拳击界工作过。
So he may have insights into all this that we just can't even pretend to have. Well, we should ask him and maybe mention it on the bonus. Yeah. But I think, I mean, what that again suggests rather like the thing on the monkeys with the Roman garrison is the ability to identify with monkeys and to admire them and perhaps even, Dominic, to love them. Yeah. So it's obviously a branch of the entertainment industry,'t it sport it is but so is cinema you've got a cinematic monkey so i just thought it would be interesting to look at the role that monkeys and particularly apes and specifically chimpanzees have played in hollywood and also in tv because a bit like rintintin the dog who we mentioned in History's Top Dogs,
所以他可能对这一切有我们无法假装拥有的见解。嗯，我们应该问问他，也许在加餐节目里提一下。是的。但我认为，这再次表明，就像罗马驻军的猴子那件事一样，人们有能力认同猴子，钦佩它们，甚至，多米尼克，去爱它们。是的。所以体育显然是娱乐业的一个分支，不是吗？它是，但电影也是。你有一只电影里的猴子，所以我只是觉得看看猴子，特别是猿类，尤其是黑猩猩在好莱坞以及电视中扮演的角色会很有趣。因为就像我们在《历史上的顶级狗》中提到的那只狗“丁丁”，
who became a big Hollywood star, chimpanzees were featuring in Hollywood shorts right from the beginning. So in 1916, there was a famous Hollywood chimpanzee couple called Napoleon and Sally who starred in a whole number of shorts. And there was one that came out in 1916 where Napoleon is called up to the army and Sally follows him and there was one that came out in 1916 where napoleon is called up to the army and sally follows him and there's a big battle and it all ends happily and i haven't actually seen this film but the account i read of it it said yeah it ends with sally eating a banana oh so that's kind of cheery but there's also on a darker note and again this is about the unknowability of the past there's an orangutan so this is the first mention of an
它成为了好莱坞的大明星，黑猩猩从一开始就出现在好莱坞短片中。所以1916年，有一对著名的好莱坞黑猩猩夫妇叫拿破仑和莎莉，他们主演了许多短片。1916年上映了一部电影，拿破仑被征召入伍，莎莉跟着他，1916年上映了一部电影，拿破仑被征召入伍，莎莉跟着他，有一场大战，结局很圆满。我其实没看过这部电影，但我读到的关于它的描述说，是的，结局是莎莉在吃香蕉。哦，那还挺开心的。但还有一个更阴暗的注脚，这又是关于过去的不可知性，有一只红毛猩猩，这是第一次提到
orangutan who is he's called pierre and he is a film star in austria so the viennese film industry no um he'd been trained for motion picture work according to the various newspapers that cover this and he i'm quoting reportedly nursed a grudge against a brutal trainer for a long time and when the opportunity arose that they were alone together high in a tree strangled the trainer and threw his body to the ground what was the trainer showing up in the tree i don't know dominic because i have googled and googled and googled this and this is all that i can find and basically it's a single sentence that is reproduced in multiple american newspapers yeah and i know nothing more about it. Oh, tantalising, Tom. Tantalising.
红毛猩猩，他叫皮埃尔，是奥地利的一位电影明星。维也纳电影业，嗯，据报道，他曾接受过电影拍摄训练，根据报道此事的各种报纸，我引用一下，他据称长期对一名残暴的训练师怀恨在心，当机会来临时，他们独自在高高的树上，他勒死了训练师，把尸体扔到了地上。训练师在树上干什么？我不知道，多米尼克，因为我谷歌了又谷歌，这就是我能找到的一切，基本上这是一句在多家美国报纸上转载的句子。是的，我对它一无所知。哦，真诱人，汤姆。真诱人。
Yeah. So again, I mean, if we have any, maybe any Austrian listeners, anyone in Vienna who were au fait with orangutan specialists. Again, please let us know.
是的。所以，如果我们要是有任何奥地利听众，或者维也纳任何熟悉红毛猩猩专家的人。再次，请告诉我们。
But of course, there have been some very famous stars who have acted opposite apes. Clint Eastwood, of course. Yeah, Clint Eastwood. Yeah.
但当然，有一些非常著名的明星曾与猿类演过对手戏。当然是克林特·伊斯特伍德。是的，克林特·伊斯特伍德。是的。
But also our old friend, Dominic. Roll Reagan. Eastwood. Yeah, but also our old friend Dominic. Roll Reagan. Roll Reagan. Yeah. So Bedtime for Bonzo, in which he's opposite a chimp. Bonzo was played by Peggy. Right.
还有我们的老朋友，多米尼克。罗纳德·里根。伊斯特伍德。是的，还有我们的老朋友多米尼克。罗纳德·里根。罗纳德·里根。是的。所以《睡前故事》（Bedtime for Bonzo），他在里面和一只黑猩猩演对手戏。邦佐是由佩吉扮演的。没错。
So that came out in 1951. But the following year, Bonzo goes to college. Confusingly, Peggy has been replaced and is placed by a chimpanzee called Bonzo. No! What are the chances?
那是1951年上映的。但第二年，邦佐上了大学。令人困惑的是，佩吉被替换了，由一只叫邦佐的黑猩猩扮演。不！这概率有多大？
I spent hours trying to work out was this a coincidence was he named after bonzo i don't know anyway crikey but dominic yeah i said they didn't just appear in films they also appeared in tv and probably the most famous one is it was a baby chimp called scatter and scatter appeared um in memphis on a TV channel there, a show called Scatter's World. And it was obviously a kind of downmarket version of the Mickey Mouse Club. So you could join the Scatter Club. But the problem is that Scatter grows up and starts to become a little bit aggressive. Oh, no.
我花了几个小时试图弄清楚这是否是个巧合，他是以邦佐命名的吗？我不知道，总之，天哪，但多米尼克，是的，我说它们不仅出现在电影里，也出现在电视里，最著名的可能是一只叫斯卡特的幼年黑猩猩，斯卡特出现在孟菲斯的一个电视频道上，一个叫《斯卡特的世界》的节目。这显然是《米老鼠俱乐部》的一个低端版本。所以你可以加入斯卡特俱乐部。但问题是斯卡特长大了，开始变得有点好斗。哦，不。
And there's quite a lot of throwing of fecal matter, which obviously I guess the children would love. I mean, they're not going to put this out. The parents wouldn't love it. And so they need to find a new home. So the guy who interestingly is a fake colonel, he's a bogus colonel in Memphis. So he turns to another bogus colonel in Memphis,
而且有很多扔粪便的行为，我想孩子们肯定会喜欢。我的意思是，他们不会播出这个。父母们不会喜欢的。所以他们需要找个新家。所以那个有趣的家伙是个假上校，他是孟菲斯的一个冒牌上校。所以他转向了孟菲斯另一个冒牌上校，
Colonel Tom Parker, because he knows that Elvis is very keen on having animals and is kind of developing a zoo in Gracelands. And so he gives Scatter to Elvis and Elvis adores Scatter. And Scatter basically has the run of Gracelands. He's ripping down curtains. He's throwing his poo around, all that kind of stuff. He's chasing the housemaids. If Elvis throws parties and people have sloped off to a bedroom to get up to what they get up to, Scatter will burst in and start throwing poo at them. And he's an upskirter.
汤姆·帕克上校，因为他知道猫王非常喜欢养动物，并且正在雅园（Graceland）开发一个动物园。所以他把斯卡特送给了猫王，猫王非常宠爱斯卡特。斯卡特基本上在雅园横行霸道。他撕掉窗帘，到处扔粪便，所有这些事情。他追赶女佣。如果猫王举办派对，人们溜进卧室去做他们做的事，斯卡特就会闯进去，开始向他们扔粪便。而且他是个偷窥裙底的人。
If a woman comes in with a skirt, he will run up and flip the skirt up and peer up inside. Oh my word, that's bad behaviour. Which Elvis finds hilarious. Right, yeah. Yeah, it's very bad behaviour. So Scatter is a difficult character, I think. And so much so that in the end he vanishes from Graceland
如果一个女人穿着裙子进来，他会跑过去掀起裙子往里看。天哪，那真是糟糕的行为。猫王觉得这很有趣。没错，是的。是的，这是非常糟糕的行为。所以我认为斯卡特是个很难对付的角色。以至于最后他从雅园消失了。
and there are conflicting accounts about what happened. So one says that he's banished by Elvis to a climate-controlled room where he dies of a broken heart. Oh, Tom. Because he's missing the king, as you would. That's sad, That is sad. And another one is that he bites a maid
关于所发生的事情，说法不一。一种说法是，他被猫王放逐到一间恒温室，最终因心碎而死。哦，汤姆。因为他想念猫王，就像你会想念一样。那太令人难过了，确实很悲伤。另一种说法是，他咬了一名女佣，
and the maid then poisons him. Crikey. That's very Shakespearean. So... Yeah. Yeah. Great drama. But again, Dominic,
然后女佣毒死了他。天哪。这非常有莎士比亚风格。所以……是的。是的。伟大的戏剧。但再说一次，多米尼克，
I mean, as you said, it's the unknowability of the past. I mean, I guess there's a serious point that monkeys are sufficiently interesting that people note them and tell stories about them. But they're not so interesting that people trouble to actually find stories about them, but they're not so interesting that people trouble to actually find out what genuinely happened. Do you think?
我的意思是，正如你所说，过去是不可知的。我的意思是，我想有一个严肃的观点，那就是猴子足够有趣，以至于人们会注意到它们并讲述关于它们的故事。但它们并没有那么有趣，以至于人们会费心去真正找出到底发生了什么。你觉得呢？
Yeah, I think that's true because a dog, you know, if a king had a dog, the dog wouldn't even show up in the sources at all. People wouldn't think to record it. Whereas a chronicler might say of somebody, he had a monkey, but then we wouldn't know where the monkey came from or what happened to the monkey, would we? But Elvis' human associates, we know all about them. I mean, everybody who's ever met him has been chronicled. And Tom, is there a well-known star who's obsessed with Elvis and emulates Elvis who has a monkey of his own? There is.
是的，我认为这是真的，因为狗，你知道，如果国王有一条狗，这条狗根本不会出现在史料中。人们不会想到去记录它。而编年史家可能会说某人养了一只猴子，但我们不会知道这只猴子从哪里来，或者它发生了什么，对吧？但猫王身边的人类伙伴，我们对他们了如指掌。我的意思是，每一个见过他的人都被记录在案了。汤姆，有没有哪位著名的明星痴迷于猫王并模仿猫王，而且自己也养了一只猴子？有的。
And this, of course, we've talked about Jacko. So here is another Jacko, but confusingly, this Jacko is the human. So, of course, it's Michael Jackson. I hadn't thought of that. Very good. And Michael Jackson is directly inspired by the example of elvis and having scatter and so michael jackson says that he wants to have a little baby chimp and this chimp comes from a texas research facility it's only eight months old and michael jackson of course calls him bubbles and in 1988 when michael jackson moves into neverland neverland
当然，我们已经谈到了杰科（Jacko）。所以这是另一个杰科，但令人困惑的是，这个杰科是个人。所以，当然，他是迈克尔·杰克逊。我没想到这一点。非常好。迈克尔·杰克逊直接受到猫王和斯卡特（Scatter）的启发，所以迈克尔·杰克逊说他想养一只小黑猩猩，这只黑猩猩来自德克萨斯州的一个研究机构，只有八个月大，迈克尔·杰克逊当然叫他“泡泡”（Bubbles）。1988年，当迈克尔·杰克逊搬进梦幻庄园（Neverland）时，
ranch so very graceland again bubbles goes with him and he sleeps in a crib in jackson's room supposedly he wears a nappy what our american listeners would call a diaper he sits at the dining table he comes with michael jackson into his private cinema to watch films and he sits there snacking on candy yeah which can't be good for the diaper is it no and he becomes I think much more than Scatter becomes a part of Elvis's image I mean Bubbles becomes a really important part of Michael Jackson's image oh totally I don't think of Scatter when I think of Elvis but I do think of Bubbles as an emblematic of Michael Jackson's weirdness and infantilism. Yeah, so I think Michael Jackson would be pleased about that because I guess he was wanting to trump the king.
梦幻庄园，又回到了雅园（Graceland）的感觉，泡泡也跟着他去了。他睡在杰克逊房间里的婴儿床上，据说他穿着尿布，也就是我们美国听众所说的“diaper”。他坐在餐桌旁，跟着迈克尔·杰克逊走进私人影院看电影，坐在那里吃糖果。是的，这对尿布肯定不好，对吧？不。我认为他变得比斯卡特更像是猫王形象的一部分。我的意思是，泡泡成为了迈克尔·杰克逊形象中非常重要的一部分。哦，完全是。想到猫王时我不会想到斯卡特，但我确实认为泡泡是迈克尔·杰克逊怪异和幼稚的象征。是的，所以我认为迈克尔·杰克逊会对此感到高兴，因为我想他当时想超越猫王。
Yes. So you're right that there is this kind of infantilizing thing. So he goes to Japan and has tea with the mayor of Osaka and takes bubbles with him. And the three of them kind of sit there. And the mayor of Osaka says, well, I've never had tea with a chimpanzee before. And he can't come to Britain because the quarantine laws won't permit it.
是的。所以你是对的，确实有这种幼稚化的东西。他去日本时和大阪市长喝茶，还带着泡泡。他们三个人就坐在那里。大阪市长说，嗯，我以前从没和黑猩猩一起喝过茶。而且他不能来英国，因为检疫法不允许。
So that's very sad. But I think there are all kinds of stories told about Bubbles that it's hard to know whether they're true. And that reflects the fact that Michael Jackson's oddness is such that it kind of encouraged all stories. So there's stories that Bubbles had his own bodyguard, that Michael Jackson had taught him to moonwalk, that Michael Jackson was doing a duet with Freddie Mercury and kept asking Bubbles what he thought. And Freddie Mercury was so pissed off that he stormed off. Yeah, I think this is actually true because I think that track was subsequently released after Freddie Mercury's death. But Bubbles a bit bit like scatter because this is what chimpanzees do
所以这很令人难过。但我认为关于泡泡流传着各种各样的故事，很难知道它们是否属实。这反映了一个事实，即迈克尔·杰克逊的古怪程度确实鼓励了所有这些故事。所以有传言说泡泡有自己的保镖，迈克尔·杰克逊教过他跳太空步，迈克尔·杰克逊在和弗雷迪·默丘里（Freddie Mercury）合唱时一直问泡泡的看法。而弗雷迪·默丘里气得拂袖而去。是的，我认为这实际上是真的，因为我认为那首歌是在弗雷迪·默丘里去世后发行的。但泡泡有点像斯卡特，因为这就是黑猩猩会做的事，
you know he grows up he becomes aggressive he gets into the whole kind of throwing poo at the housemaids thing this running thing that the housemates in rock stars palaces hate yeah chimpanzees basically and so eventually he has to be retired so 2003 bubbles is sent off to a pet trainer in 2005 he is sent to a sanctuary for apes in florida where he stays to this day still alive yeah that's nice so i looked up the site yeah the website for the center for great apes website because you can sponsor him it's not under an alias or something no he's there as bubbles and um that all these kind of various apes and they describe them and if you want to you can sponsor them and it says of bubbles that he will occasionally spit water or throw sand with amazing accuracy at strangers just to see how they react yeah so he's still a bit of a funster
你知道，他长大了，变得好斗，开始做那种向女佣扔粪便的事情，这种摇滚明星宫殿里的女佣们讨厌的事情。是的，黑猩猩基本上就是这样。所以最终他不得不退役。2003年，泡泡被送给了一位宠物训练师。2005年，他被送往佛罗里达州的一个猿类保护区，至今仍在那里，还活着。是的，那很好。所以我查了那个网站，是的，大猿中心（Center for Great Apes）的网站，因为你可以资助他。不是用化名什么的？不，他就在那里，名字叫泡泡。嗯，所有这些各种各样的猿类，他们描述了它们，如果你愿意，你可以资助它们。关于泡泡，上面写着他偶尔会向陌生人喷水或扔沙子，而且非常精准，只是为了看看他们的反应。是的，所以他仍然是个顽童。
but bubbles caregivers consider him to be artistic gentle and shy and i think this is really sad he often will turn his back when he sees a camera oh so yeah he's traumatized by paparazzi ruined by yeah his experience of fame yeah that's what fame does to you tom sad story but not as sad as jack mccack see tom you're projecting there we don't know that Jacko Macacko... But it's a possibility he had his jaw ripped off. I mean, I know he might not have done, but he got stuffed. Yeah, that's all true. Our animal rights listeners will be horrified by
但泡泡的护理人员认为他很有艺术天赋，温柔而害羞。我觉得这真的很可悲，当他看到相机时，他经常会转过身去。哦，所以是的，他被狗仔队伤害了，被他经历的名声毁了。是的，这就是名声对你做的事，汤姆。悲伤的故事，但没有杰克·马卡克（Jacko Macacko）那么悲伤。看，汤姆，你在投射你的想法，我们不知道杰克·马卡克……但他的下巴被扯掉是有可能的。我的意思是，我知道他可能没有，但他被做成了标本。是的，那都是真的。我们的动物权利听众会被
this conversation. We should probably move on before our audience completely plummets. Join us after the break for more exciting historical monkeys. See you then. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
这段对话吓坏的。在我们的听众完全流失之前，我们可能应该继续了。休息后回来，还有更多令人兴奋的历史猴子故事。到时候见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to our episode on history's top monkeys. We've had a fair few, but Dominic, we've got more top monkeys. We've got them. Yeah, we do. So I thought what we would do now is we're a cosmopolitan podcast. I think we haven't done a lot of South African history on The Rest is History. I think we should.
那是 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到我们关于历史上顶级猴子的剧集。我们已经讲了不少了，但多米尼克，我们还有更多顶级猴子。我们有。是的，我们有。所以我认为我们现在要做的是，我们是一个国际化的播客。我觉得我们在《剩下的就是历史》（The Rest is History）中没有做太多南非历史。我觉得我们应该做。
And I've got a couple of South African monkeys that I think are extraordinary characters, Tom. So we mentioned in the first half that our executive producer, Jack Davenport, is called Jack. And I've actually got two more monkeys, both called Jack. So one is Jack the Signalman. I'll just mention him quite briefly. Jack the Signalman is a baboon. Oh, brilliant to get a baboon on the show. Yeah, great to get a baboon on the rest of his history.
我还有几只南非猴子，我认为它们是非常非凡的角色，汤姆。所以我们在上半部分提到我们的执行制片人杰克·达文波特（Jack Davenport）叫杰克。我实际上还有两只猴子，也都叫杰克。一只是信号员杰克（Jack the Signalman）。我先简单提一下他。信号员杰克是一只狒狒。哦，能请到一只狒狒上节目真是太棒了。是的，能请到一只狒狒上《剩下的就是历史》真是太好了。
He worked for the Cape Town to Port Elizabeth Railway. When you say he worked? In the 1880s as well. So he belonged to a man called James Wide. James Wide was nicknamed Jumper because he used to jump between the railway carriages. And one day he mistimed his jump oh no he lost both his legs oh dear so he bought this monkey this baboon to help him as a
他为开普敦到伊丽莎白港的铁路工作。当你说是他工作时？也是在19世纪80年代。所以他属于一个叫詹姆斯·怀德（James Wide）的人。詹姆斯·怀德绰号“跳跃者”（Jumper），因为他过去常在火车车厢之间跳跃。有一天他跳错了时间，哦不，他失去了双腿。哦天哪，所以他买了这只猴子，这只狒狒来帮助他，作为
carer the baboon would push him around in a trolley and he taught the baboon jack how to use the signals now according to the the periodical the railway Tom, who knew from 1908, James White, quote, trained the baboon to such perfection that he was able to sit in his cabin stuffing birds, etc. Deep water. While the animal, which was chained up outside, pulled all the levers and points. Now, one day, somebody saw this on the railway, and they complained to the railway authorities. And they sent, the Cape Town supporters of the railway sent an investigator called George B. Howe. And he wrote in his report,
护理员。这只狒狒会用手推车推着他到处走，他还教这只叫杰克的狒狒如何使用信号。现在，根据1908年的《铁路》杂志，汤姆，谁知道呢，詹姆斯·怀德，“将这只狒狒训练得如此完美，以至于他能够坐在小屋里填充鸟类标本等等。深水。而那只被拴在外面的动物则拉动所有的杠杆和道岔。”现在，有一天，有人在铁路上看到了这一幕，他们向铁路当局投诉。他们派了，开普敦的铁路支持者派了一名调查员叫乔治·B·豪（George B. Howe）。他在报告中写道，
Jack knows the signal whistle as well as I do at every one of the levers. It was very touching to see his fondness for his master. As I drew near, they were both sitting on the trolley, the baboon's arms around his master's neck, the other stroking wide's face. So it's quite a touching story. He was officially employed by the railway. He was paid 20 cents a day and half a bottle of beer a week. And it is said that in nine years with the railway, he never made a single mistake.
“杰克知道信号哨声，就像我一样，也知道每一个杠杆。看到他对主人的喜爱非常感人。当我走近时，他们都坐在手推车上，狒狒的手臂搂着主人的脖子，另一只手抚摸着怀德的脸。”所以这是一个相当感人的故事。他被铁路正式录用。他每天领20美分，每周半瓶啤酒。据说在铁路工作的九年里，他从未犯过一次错误。
So there's a lesson there for Britain's railways, Tom. Yes. So the government could just sack everyone involved on the railways and bring in baboons. Exactly. I mean, I was wondering
所以这对英国铁路来说是个教训，汤姆。是的。所以政府可以解雇铁路上的所有人，然后雇佣狒狒。完全正确。我的意思是，我当时在想
how people on the trains felt about this. Disturbed. This guy complained to the authorities. But if you're on a train and you're approaching a point that's operated
火车上的人对此有何感想。不安。这家伙向当局投诉了。但如果你在火车上，你正在接近一个由
by a baboon, I'd feel a bit nervous. I mean, I don't want to seem baboonist. No. But in a sense, Tom, aren't we always getting trains operated by a baboon i'd feel a bit nervous i mean i don't want to seem baboonist no but in a sense tom aren't we always getting trains operated by apes i mean in a very real sense we are yes i guess we are i mean i'm doing a podcast with a load of apes right now i mean so are you yeah so anyway i really wanted to focus on another south african baboon because south africa is very strong in this department and this is a chap called Corporal Jackie.
狒狒操作的道岔，我会感到有点紧张。我的意思是，我不想显得有“狒狒歧视”。不。但从某种意义上说，汤姆，难道我们不是一直都在乘坐由狒狒操作的火车吗？我感到有点紧张。我的意思是，我不想显得有“狒狒歧视”。不。但从某种意义上说，汤姆，难道我们不是一直都在乘坐由猿类操作的火车吗？我的意思是，在非常真实的意义上，我们是。是的，我想我们是。我的意思是，我现在正和一群猿类一起做播客。我的意思是，你也是。是的，所以无论如何，我真的很想关注另一只南非狒狒，因为南非在这个领域非常强，这就是一个叫杰基下士（Corporal Jackie）的家伙。
When you say chap, do you mean a baboon? Yeah, he's a baboon. But I'm inclusive in my language. He lived on a farm in South Africa with a chap called Albert Marr who looked after him. And Albert Marr was drafted in 1915, was conscripted to go to the Great War. And he took Jackie, his baboon, with him, and he became a mascot for the 3rd South African Infantry Regiment, who were from the Transvaal.
当你说是“家伙”时，你是说一只狒狒？是的，他是一只狒狒。但我说话很包容。他住在南非的一个农场里，和一个叫阿尔伯特·马尔（Albert Marr）的家伙住在一起，马尔照顾他。阿尔伯特·马尔在1915年被征召入伍，去参加第一次世界大战。他带着他的狒狒杰基一起去了，他成为了南非第三步兵团的吉祥物，他们来自德兰士瓦（Transvaal）。
Is he very like the Romans? Very like the Romans, because he was given a cap, his own rations, he was given a paybook, and I've got all this from the South African Military History website, the Observation Post, so a big shout out to them. Jackie wore his uniform with some panache he was also known to light up a cigarette or pipe for his pals he had a sharp salute for any officer passing him he'd stand at ease when commanded to do so placing his feet apart and hands behind his back in the military style and at the mess table he used a knife and fork and a teacup in the proper
他很像罗马人吗？非常像罗马人，因为他被发了一顶帽子，他自己的口粮，他被发了一本工资手册，我所有这些都是从南非军事历史网站“观察哨”（Observation Post）得来的，所以向他们大声致敬。杰基戴着他的制服，很有风度。他还以给伙伴们点烟或点烟斗而闻名。他对任何经过他的军官都会行一个标准的军礼。当接到命令时，他会站立休息，双脚分开，双手背在身后，采用军事姿势。在食堂餐桌上，他用刀叉和茶杯，方式非常
manner and i have to say to people if you google corporal jackie he looks hilarious because he's just this baboon looking completely nonplussed where it's military because in planet of the apes the soldiers of the orangutans aren't they yeah but it might be slightly similar i guess so yes he saw a lot of action so he first saw action at the somme in 1916 he and albert mar lived to tell the tale Then they were sent to Egypt and Albert Maher was shot in the shoulder in Egypt. And Jackie was with him and Jackie licked the wound while others went to get help. And he wasn't scared. He didn't run away. No. Well, there's a terrible story coming up. So they went back to France and they were in
得体。我必须对大家说，如果你在谷歌上搜索“杰基下士”，他看起来非常滑稽，因为他只是一只狒狒，看起来对军事完全不知所措。因为在《人猿星球》里，猩猩士兵不是吗？是的，但我想可能有点相似。所以是的，他经历了很多战斗。所以他第一次在1916年的索姆河战役中看到战斗。他和阿尔伯特·马尔幸存了下来。然后他们被派往埃及，阿尔伯特·马尔在埃及肩膀中弹。杰基和他在一起，杰基舔了伤口，而其他人去寻求帮助。他并不害怕。他没有逃跑。不。好吧，一个可怕的故事即将到来。所以他们回到了法国，他们在
France in the trenches and there was a huge explosion in the trenches and some shrapnel hit Jackie in the leg and arm and stretcher bearers came and he was trying to sort of burrow into the ground to escape more firing.
法国的战壕里，战壕里发生了巨大的爆炸，一些弹片击中了杰基的腿和手臂，担架员来了，他试图钻进地里以躲避更多的炮火。
How awful. He wouldn't allow himself to be taken away by the stretcher but eventually they did and the doctor was so, you know, he's kind of working
太可怕了。他不允许自己被担架带走，但最终他们还是带走了他，医生非常，你知道，他正在
patching up all these people that they bring a baboon in. He obviously made an impression on the doctor because he wrote an account of it and he said it was a pathetic sight the little fellow
忙着包扎他们带来的所有人，结果带进来一只狒狒。他显然给医生留下了深刻的印象，因为他写了一份关于这件事的记录，他说那是一个可怜的景象，那个小家伙
carried by his keeper lay moaning in pain the man crying his eyes out in sympathy you must do something for him he saved my life in Egypt he nursed me through dysentery the baboon was badly wounded
由他的饲养员抱着，痛苦地呻吟着，那个人因为同情而哭得稀里哗啦。“你必须为他做点什么。他在埃及救了我的命。他照顾我度过了痢疾。”那只狒狒受了重伤，
the left leg hanging with shreds of muscle another jagged wound in his right arm they gave him chloroform they had a big debate will this kill him but they gave him chloroform. They had a big debate, will this kill him, that they gave him chloroform. He lapped up the chloroform as if it had been whiskey,
左腿挂着肌肉碎片，右臂上有另一个锯齿状的伤口。他们给他用了氯仿。他们进行了一场大辩论，这会杀了他吗？但他们还是给他用了氯仿。他们进行了一场大辩论，这会杀了他吗？但他们还是给他用了氯仿。他像喝威士忌一样舔着氯仿，
and he was well under in a remarkably short time. It was a simple matter to amputate his leg with scissors, and then I cleaned the wounds and dressed them as well as I could. So Corporal Jackie has lost his leg. It's out of the chloroform, whatever. He wakes up. They send them back to England to convalesce, him and Albert Marr. He's a tremendous celebrity in England.
他在非常短的时间内就完全昏迷了。用剪刀截掉他的腿是一件简单的事情，然后我尽可能地清理了伤口并包扎好。所以杰基下士失去了一条腿。他从氯仿中醒来，无论如何。他们把他和阿尔伯特·马尔送回英国疗养。他在英国是一位巨大的名人。
He marches. He doesn't march. He hops, presumably. In the Lord Mayor's show, the Lord Mayor's parade, Tom. He ends up raising money. They go around the country raising money for the Red Cross. People were paid half a crown each to shake Jackie by the hand. And five shillings. If you paid five shillings,
他行军。他不行军。大概是跳着走。在伦敦市长的游行中，伦敦市长的游行，汤姆。他最终筹集了资金。他们走遍全国为红十字会筹款。人们每人支付半克朗来和杰基握手。还有五先令。如果你支付五先令，
you got to kiss him. So people are paying this. They raise a lot of money. They go back to South Africa. And again, he was present. He hopped through another parade, a peace parade in Church Square, Pretoria, on the 31st of July, 1920.
你就可以亲吻他。所以人们都在付钱。他们筹集了很多钱。他们回到南非。他再次出席了。他在1920年7月31日比勒陀利亚教堂广场的和平游行中跳着走过。
He was given a medal, and they went back to their family farm. There's a sad coda to this story though. Both Ma and Jackie were a bit affected by shell shock. And actually in May, 1921, there was a tremendous storm over the veldt of the high veldt, Tom,
他被授予了一枚奖章，然后他们回到了他们的家庭农场。不过这个故事有一个悲伤的尾声。马尔和杰基都受到了一点炮弹休克（shell shock）的影响。实际上在1921年5月，高地草原上空发生了一场巨大的风暴，汤姆，
and a great crash of thunder. And Jackie obviously thought this was the return of kind of the Germans. He had a heart attack and died. Oh, dear. I was going to ask about shell shock. Yeah. I had not realized that baboons could get shell shock. Well, why wouldn't they?
一声巨大的雷鸣。杰基显然认为这是德国人回来了。他心脏病发作死了。哦，天哪。我正要问关于炮弹休克的事。是的。我没意识到狒狒也会得炮弹休克。好吧，为什么不呢？
If other apes can get shell shock, Tom. Yeah. So he's a very impressive character, I think, Corporal Jackie. Yeah. He doesn't seem to have taken part in fighting, but he's... Tending to the men. He's tending to the men and keeping their spirits up. And saluting and everything.
如果其他猿类也会得炮弹休克，汤姆。是的。所以我觉得杰基下士是一个非常令人印象深刻的角色。是的。他似乎没有参加战斗，但他……照顾士兵。他在照顾士兵，保持他们的士气。还行军礼什么的。
Yeah. And eating his rations with a knife and fork and generally behaving i think very well good well i mean i like to think there's a kind of bond between him and the unknown macaque in the pyrenees yeah that's nice it's a nice link yeah so these have all been very inspiring stories stories that are all about the bond between human and ape or monkey or whatever. But my next story is a darker one. So we're in the Napoleonic Wars and we are in Hartlepool, which is in County Durham. Tom, I know where this is going. And the good people of Hartlepool, fishermen mostly, They look out to sea and there they observe a French ship. A storm is brewing. The French ship gets dashed against the rocks. Everyone drowns, except for a single survivor. And this survivor is a monkey. And again, pursuing the military
是的。而且用刀叉吃他的口粮，表现得非常好。好，我的意思是，我喜欢认为他和比利牛斯山脉中那只不知名的猕猴之间有一种联系。是的，那很好，这是一个很好的联系。所以这些都是非常鼓舞人心的故事，都是关于人类和猿类或猴子或任何东西之间的联系的故事。但我的下一个故事是一个更黑暗的故事。所以我们在拿破仑战争时期，我们在哈特尔普尔（Hartlepool），它在达勒姆郡。汤姆，我知道这要去哪里。哈特尔普尔的好人们，主要是渔民，他们望向大海，在那里他们观察到一艘法国船。一场风暴正在酝酿。法国船被撞在岩石上。每个人都淹死了，除了一个幸存者。而这个幸存者是一只猴子。再次追求军事
theme, or in this case, a nautical theme, the monkey is in a French uniform. So he's kind of dressed in a Marine's uniform. And this alarms the locals who have never seen a monkey and indeed have never seen a French person. Well, this is the thing. How would you know? Exactly. And so they assume that this strange creature in the military uniform, that this is what the French look like. Hairy. Talking strange gibberish.
主题，或者在这种情况下，一个航海主题，这只猴子穿着法国制服。所以他穿着海军陆战队的制服。这惊动了当地人，他们从未见过猴子，事实上也从未见过法国人。好吧，这就是问题所在。你怎么会知道？完全正确。所以他们认为这个穿着军装的奇怪生物，这就是法国人的样子。多毛。说着奇怪的胡言乱语。
Ill-groomed. Not speaking English. So they assume that he must be a spy. And all the fishermen gather around on the beach and they start interrogating the monkey. And of course, the monkey can't answer their questions. And this simply confirms for them that he's a spy. Yeah, you can't take chances, Tom. And a Frenchman.
衣冠不整。不会说英语。所以他们认为他一定是个间谍。所有的渔民都聚集在海滩上，开始审问这只猴子。当然，猴子无法回答他们的问题。这简单地证实了他们认为他是个间谍。是的，你不能冒险，汤姆。而且是个法国人。
Yeah. And so they hang the monkey. And from this point onwards, the people of Hartlepool are known as monkey hangers. Now, listeners may be wondering, is this story actually true? Or is it invented by their near neighbours? Don't do this, Tom. Come on, don't do this.
是的。所以他们绞死了这只猴子。从这一点开始，哈特尔普尔的人们被称为“吊猴人”（monkey hangers）。现在，听众可能想知道，这个故事是真的吗？还是被他们的近邻编造出来的？别这样，汤姆。来吧，别这样。
Well, I mean, who knows, Dominic? Who knows? A very similar story is told about a number of isolated fishing communities along the length of Britain. So there's one in Cornwall, there's one in Scotland. I mean, same kind of thing. And there is a song that is very popular in the music halls of Britain in the mid-19th century, sung by a guy called Ned Corvin. Should I sing it for you? I think everybody would enjoy that, not just me. In former times, mid-war and strife, when French invasion threatened life,
好吧，我的意思是，谁知道呢，多米尼克？谁知道呢？关于英国沿海的一些孤立的渔业社区，流传着非常相似的故事。所以康沃尔有一个，苏格兰有一个。我的意思是，同样的事情。而且有一首歌在19世纪中叶的英国音乐厅非常流行，由一个叫内德·科文（Ned Corvin）的家伙演唱。我应该为你唱吗？我想每个人都会喜欢的，不仅仅是我。在过去，战争和冲突时期，当法国入侵威胁生命时，
and all was armoured to the knife. The fisherman hung the monkey. Oh, Durham, Durham, Durham, Durham, Durham, Durham, Durham, Durham, Durham. That's nice, Fitz. Can you guess what the next line is? Is it Durham, Durham, Durham, Durham, Durham? It is Durham, Durham, Durham, Durham, Durham, the fisherman hung the monkey. Oh, and so it goes on for quite a while and I won't sing anymore. And I think it is a generally held theory that actually this story emerges from the song rather than the other way around. Oh, how interesting that is. The story was created to explain the song. Yeah, I think the idea for the song came first.
一切都武装到牙齿。渔民绞死了猴子。哦，达勒姆，达勒姆，达勒姆……那很好，菲茨。你能猜出下一句是什么吗？是达勒姆，达勒姆……吗？是的，达勒姆，达勒姆……渔民绞死了猴子。哦，就这样持续了很长一段时间，我不会再唱了。而且我认为这是一个普遍持有的理论，即实际上这个故事是从这首歌中产生的，而不是反过来。哦，这太有趣了。这个故事是为了解释这首歌而创作的。是的，我认为这首歌的想法先出现。
But there is a massive twist to this story, isn't there, about Hartlepool and monkeys? There is a massive twist because actually this monkey who gets hanged not only becomes a real character, but becomes the first ape in this episode to win political office. Yes, indirectly I think it's fair to say. And the story begins on the 31st of October 1999 with Hartlepool United Football Club. Again, this kind of link between monkeys and sport, also a kind of running theme. And the football club want a mascot and they decide, well, let's have a monkey, this hanged monkey. And so they call the monkey Hangus. So H apostrophe, Angus, Hangus. And they employ various people to play this mascot. And the key figure in this story, a historic figure,
但关于哈特尔普尔和猴子，这个故事有一个巨大的转折，不是吗？有一个巨大的转折，因为实际上这只被绞死的猴子不仅成为了一个真实的角色，而且成为了本集中第一只赢得公职的猿类。是的，间接来说，我认为这样说是公平的。故事开始于1999年10月31日，哈特尔普尔联队足球俱乐部。同样，这种猴子和体育之间的联系，也是一种贯穿的主题。足球俱乐部想要一个吉祥物，他们决定，好吧，让我们养一只猴子，这只被绞死的猴子。所以他们叫这只猴子“汉格斯”（Hangus）。所以H撇号，Angus，Hangus。他们雇佣了各种各样的人来扮演这个吉祥物。而这个故事中的关键人物，一个历史人物，
is the second guy who wins the chance to play Hengist. This is a man called Stuart Drummond, who is a local from Hartlepool. He's studied foreign languages. He's worked on cruise ships. So he's a man of the world. And he's very excited at the opportunity. He's a big Hartlepool fan. He dresses up as Hengus every week he gambles around
是第二个赢得扮演汉格斯机会的家伙。这是一个叫斯图尔特·德拉蒙德（Stuart Drummond）的人，他是哈特尔普尔当地人。他学习过外语。他在游轮上工作过。所以他是一个见过世面的人。他对这个机会感到非常兴奋。他是哈特尔普尔的忠实粉丝。他每周都打扮成汉格斯，他在
on the pitch he is twice escorted by the police out of the ground for having simulated sex oh no once with a steward and once with an inflatable doll and when Hartlepool are playing Chester yeah away so they're at Chester Hengus is asked to perform the halftime lottery draw and he gets so into his role that he pulls all the tickets out of the tumbola throws up the air and walks away without picking a winner so very authentic yeah very authentic monkey behavior he's really in character it's method yeah yeah and so he's tremendously popular he's probably britain's most popular football mascot and a source of great pride, not just to the fans of Hartlepool United, but the whole city.
球场上蹦蹦跳跳，他曾两次被警察护送出球场，因为他模拟性行为。哦不，一次是和一个服务员，一次是和一个充气娃娃。当哈特尔普尔在切斯特比赛时，是的，客场，所以他们在切斯特，汉格斯被要求进行中场彩票抽奖，他太投入角色了，以至于他把所有的票都从摇奖机里拉出来，扔向空中，然后走开了，没有选出获胜者。所以非常真实，是的，非常真实的猴子行为。他真的进入了角色，这是方法派表演。是的，是的。所以他非常受欢迎，他可能是英国最受欢迎的足球吉祥物，也是哈特尔普尔联队球迷，乃至整个城市的巨大骄傲。
So when in 2002, this is when the Blair government is very keen on directly elected mayors and Hartlepool decides that, yeah, we'll go for it. We'll have a directly elected mayor. And so Hengist wants to run for mayor, Hengist, a.k.a. Stuart Drummond. And he's told that he can't enter the mayoral race as Hengist. He has to do it as Stuart Drummond. But he campaigns dressed as the monkey the whole way through. And he does it as a stunt. Yeah.
所以当2002年，这是布莱尔政府非常热衷于直接选举市长的时候，哈特尔普尔决定，是的，我们会尝试一下。我们将有一位直接选举的市长。所以汉格斯想要竞选市长，汉格斯，也就是斯图尔特·德拉蒙德。他被告知他不能以汉格斯的名义参加市长竞选。他必须以斯图尔特·德拉蒙德的名义。但他全程打扮成猴子的样子进行竞选。他把它当作一个噱头。是的。
It's a couple of things because it's a stunt for the football club. But also, when Tony Blair introduced elected mayors, there was a lot of public antipathy to it, wasn't there? Because a lot of people thought, oh, it's an extra layer of government. We don't need it. It's expensive. And there was a lot of public antipathy to it wasn't there because a lot of people thought oh it's an extra layer of government we don't need it it's expensive and there was a sort of protest against yes so the whole thing has been pushed by peter mandelson who is tony blair's kind of svengali eminence greece yeah and he's the mp for hartlepool so he's very much in favor of it so it's a kind of a peter mandelson against local government embroil you're going on yeah the chairman of harley pool united you're right he thinks this is a tremendous stunt so he puts the money up because you have to you have to pay a deposit if you're running to be an MP and if you don't get sufficient votes and you lose it so he puts the money up for that and it is done as a stunt so the campaign slogan
这是几件事，因为这是足球俱乐部的噱头。而且，当托尼·布莱尔引入民选市长时，公众对此有很多反感，不是吗？因为很多人认为，哦，这是额外的一层政府。我们不需要它。它很贵。而且公众对此有很多反感，不是吗？因为很多人认为，哦，这是额外的一层政府。我们不需要它。它很贵。而且有一种抗议，是的。所以这一切都是由彼得·曼德尔森（Peter Mandelson）推动的，他是托尼·布莱尔的某种“拉斯普京”（svengali），幕后操纵者。是的，他是哈特尔普尔的议员，所以他非常支持它。所以这是一种彼得·曼德尔森对抗地方政府的纠葛，你懂的。是的，哈特尔普尔联队的主席，你是对的，他认为这是一个巨大的噱头。所以他出了钱，因为你必须，如果你要竞选议员，你必须支付押金，如果你没有获得足够的选票，你就会失去它。所以他为此出了钱，而且它是作为一个噱头完成的。所以竞选口号
is vote for hangers he gives the monkeys right and there isn't much of a manifesto but one of them is that every school child in the town will have a banana yeah but there are some kind of serious elements so they're very keen on promoting sports facilities so they want to improve sports facilities for people generally in the town there's a local sports center that's threatened with closure and also they want to cut the number of councillors and the local government so again that's the kind of idea that it's a kind of anti-government thing, really. And amazingly, he beats the Labour candidate by 500 votes. And Mandelson is furious and takes Stuart Drummond to one side, calls him a disgrace, says he's made the whole town a laughingstock. And I think Stuart Drummond somehow
是“投票给汉格斯”。他给猴子权利，而且没有太多的宣言，但其中之一是镇上的每个学童都会得到一根香蕉。是的，但有一些严肃的元素，所以他们非常热衷于推广体育设施，所以他们想改善镇上人们的体育设施。有一个当地的体育中心面临关闭的威胁，他们还想削减议员人数和地方政府。所以同样，这是一种反政府的想法，真的。令人惊讶的是，他以500票的优势击败了工党候选人。曼德尔森非常愤怒，把斯图尔特·德拉蒙德拉到一边，称他为耻辱，说他让整个城镇成了笑柄。我想斯图尔特·德拉蒙德以某种方式
reveals that he speaks French and German. And then Peter Mandelson suddenly thinks, oh, actually, this is a guy who will raise our profile on the international stage and suddenly turns around and says it's tremendous for Hartlepool. And he's tremendous. You know, he's a great success. He makes a great fist of it. He won three terms. Yes, he did. He did. And Labour is so cross at always losing that eventually the councillors convene a referendum to abolish the
透露他会说法语和德语。然后彼得·曼德尔森突然想，哦，实际上，这是一个能在国际舞台上提升我们形象的人，突然转过身来说这对哈特尔普尔来说是巨大的。而且他很棒。你知道，他非常成功。他做得很好。他赢得了三个任期。是的，他做到了。他做到了。工党对总是输感到非常生气，以至于最终议员们召集了一次公投来废除
directly elected mayor so hangus is the only the only mayor yeah yeah the one and only elected mayor i'm just looking at the headline in the northern echo monkey is mayor the national post in canada reports it monkey wins mayoralty, regains human form. But again, it's this theme, isn't it, of kind of the permeability of humans and apes and monkeys and things. Well, actually, that's a beautiful link, actually, Tom, into the next little monkey story that I had. Because I think there is a kind of, it's the idea of the slippage, isn't there, between the yeah of monkey and human so 1964 an art gallery in gothenburg exhibited four paintings by the french avant-garde artist pierre brasso and it was quite well reviewed so the gutterberg posten sent rolf anderberg its top critic and anderberg wrote brasso paints with powerful strokes but also with clear determination his brush strokes twist with
直接选举的市长。所以汉格斯是唯一的，唯一的市长。是的，是的，唯一一位民选市长。我正在看《北方回声报》（Northern Echo）的头条新闻，“猴子是市长”。加拿大的《国家邮报》（National Post）报道，“猴子赢得市长职位，恢复人形”。但再说一次，这是这个主题，不是吗，关于人类和猿类和猴子等东西的渗透性。好吧，实际上，这是一个美丽的联系，实际上，汤姆，进入我有的下一个小猴子故事。因为我认为有一种，这是关于滑移的想法，不是吗，在猴子和人类之间。所以1964年，哥德堡的一家艺术画廊展出了法国前卫艺术家皮埃尔·布拉索（Pierre Brasso）的四幅画作，评论相当不错。所以《哥德堡邮报》（Goteborgs-Posten）派出了他们的顶级评论家罗尔夫·安德伯格（Rolf Anderberg），安德伯格写道：“布拉索用强有力的笔触作画，但也带有清晰的决心。他的笔触扭曲着，带有
furious fastidiousness he's an artist who performs with the delicacy of a ballet dancer and um it was therefore embarrassing for when it turned out that these paintings had been done by somebody called peter who was a four-year-old chimpanzee from uh boros zoo in uh in sweden and this was a hoax that had been constructed by a journalist called daca axelson who was a journalist at gothenburg's tabloid newspaper the good books tidning and so they must have very much enjoyed basically fooling the broadsheet the posh broadsheet apparently what happened was that he persuaded the zookeeper to give peter some paint and a brush. Peter initially ate the paint.
狂暴的挑剔。他是一位表演时带有芭蕾舞演员细腻感的艺术家。”嗯，当发现这些画作是由一个叫彼得的四岁黑猩猩完成时，这很尴尬，他来自瑞典的布罗斯动物园（Boros Zoo）。这是一个由记者达卡·阿克塞尔森（Daka Axelson）策划的恶作剧，他是哥德堡小报《哥德堡日报》（Goteborgs-Tidning）的记者。所以他们一定非常享受愚弄那份昂贵的宽幅报纸。显然发生的事情是，他说服了动物园管理员给彼得一些颜料和画笔。彼得最初吃了颜料。
Very surrealist. But eventually it was persuaded to smear it onto the canvas. Now, apparently, I read at the Museum of Hoaxes website, Tom, top quality research, that Peter had a load of bananas with him. And the more bananas he ate, the more creative and the more progressive his artistic vision became. A Swedish art investor actually bought one of these pictures for the equivalent of about £500.
非常超现实。但最终他被说服将其涂抹在画布上。现在，显然，我在“恶作剧博物馆”（Museum of Hoaxes）网站上读到，汤姆，顶级质量的研究，彼得带了一堆香蕉。他吃的香蕉越多，他的艺术视野就越有创造力和进步性。一位瑞典艺术投资者实际上以相当于500英镑的价格买下了其中一幅画。
I mean, were they good? No, they're terrible. But actually, do you know what? It's the 1960s. So, you know, who can tell? The critic, to be fair, Rolf Anderberg, who had praised them, said when it was revealed,
我的意思是，它们好吗？不，它们很糟糕。但实际上，你知道吗？那是20世纪60年代。所以，你知道，谁能说得准呢？评论家，公平地说，罗尔夫·安德伯格，他曾称赞过它们，当真相大白时，他说，
he said, they're still the best pictures in the exhibition yeah that's funny and it made me think about so the most famous artistic monkey these days
他说，“它们仍然是展览中最好的画作。”是的，那很有趣。这让我想到了，所以这些天最著名的艺术猴子
is a painting rather than an artist do you remember the story of the Eke Homo in Borjas yes the thing of Jesus
是一幅画，而不是一位艺术家。你还记得博尔哈斯（Borjas）的《看这个人》（Ecce Homo）的故事吗？是的，关于耶稣的那件事，
which was restored by an elderly lady a 1930s fresco and she basically turned him into a monkey so that's probably the most famous artistic monkey there was another um chimpanzee that actually impressed picasso and this i think was sponsored by desmond morris oh very good who wrote the naked ape yes so desmond morris was an amazing guy he was a surrealist painter i mean he was a
被一位老太太修复了，一幅20世纪30年代的壁画，她基本上把他变成了一只猴子。所以那可能是最著名的艺术猴子。还有另一只黑猩猩，实际上给毕加索留下了深刻印象，我认为这是由德斯蒙德·莫里斯（Desmond Morris）赞助的。哦，非常好，他写了《裸猿》（The Naked Ape）。是的，所以德斯蒙德·莫里斯是一个了不起的人，他是一位超现实主义画家，我的意思是，他
friend i think with picasso but he was also mean, he was friends, I think, with Picasso. But he was also, I think he was the keeper of the mammals at London Zoo and a primatologist. I mean, his book, The Naked Ape, which I think was published in 1967, a very 60s book. It's very groovy, isn't it? It is. It's all about how earlobes are erogenous. It is, but it's very, people diss it now. But the introduction, there are 193 living species of monkeys and apes.
是毕加索的朋友，我想。但他也是，我的意思是，他是朋友，我想，和毕加索。但他也是，我想他是伦敦动物园的哺乳动物管理员和灵长类动物学家。我的意思是，他的书《裸猿》，我认为出版于1967年，一本非常60年代的书。它非常时髦，不是吗？是的。它全是关于耳垂如何是性感带的。是的，但它非常，人们现在贬低它。但引言里说，有193种现存的猴子和猿类。
192 of them are covered with hair. The exception is a naked ape self-named Homo sapiens. This unusual and highly successful species spends a great deal of time examining his higher motives and an equal amount of time studiously ignoring his fundamental ones. He's proud that he has the biggest brain of all the primates, but attempts to conceal the fact that he also has the biggest penis. Yes. So the highest ratio of penis size to body mass of any primate, apparently.
其中192种覆盖着毛发。例外是自称为“智人”（Homo sapiens）的裸猿。这个不寻常且高度成功的物种花费大量时间审视他更高的动机，同样多的时间刻意忽视他基本的动机。他为自己拥有所有灵长类动物中最大的大脑而自豪，但试图掩盖他也有最大的阴茎这一事实。是的。所以显然是任何灵长类动物中阴茎大小与体重比率最高的。
Yes. Very exciting. So Desmond Morris, I mean, like a lot of 60s stuff, it's kind of sex obsessed, isn't it? Yeah. Well, he says that humans are naked because it enhances tactile pleasure. Is that his claim? Yeah.
是的。非常令人兴奋。所以德斯蒙德·莫里斯，我的意思是，像很多60年代的东西一样，它有点性痴迷，不是吗？是的。好吧，他说人类是裸体的，因为它增强了触觉快感。这是他的主张吗？是的。
And he says that the human breast is rounded because it enhances sexual pleasure or something. I mean, it's so 60s. Because it comes out in 1967, I think, doesn't it? I think it's fair to say that feminist critics have a strong dislike for The Naked Ape. Not unreasonably. But I think it was an interesting book. And it's very much of its time. Because thinking of
他说人类的乳房是圆形的，因为它增强了性快感什么的。我的意思是，它太60年代了。因为它出版于1967年，我想，不是吗？我认为公平地说，女性主义评论家对《裸猿》有强烈的反感。并非没有道理。但我认为这是一本有趣的书。而且它非常符合那个时代。因为想到
human beings as essentially animals is no better than any other animal and the as it were the bestial impulses in the human soul
人类本质上是动物，并不比任何其他动物更好，以及人类灵魂中所谓的兽性冲动，
that's a very 1960s post second world war kind of fascination and he Desmond Morris like Bubbles is still alive
那是非常20世纪60年代二战后的那种迷恋。而且他，德斯蒙德·莫里斯，像泡泡一样，仍然活着。
is he? yeah he lives in Ireland so two characters from this podcast are still with us yeah and may well both be listening
是吗？是的，他住在爱尔兰。所以这个播客中的两个角色仍然和我们在一起。是的，而且可能都在听
to the rest of the history right now be nice to think wouldn't it yeah so actually mention of Desmond Morris brings us to our final ape
《剩下的就是历史》现在。想到这一点会很好，不是吗？是的，所以实际上提到德斯蒙德·莫里斯把我们带到了我们最后的猿类，
and the most important and actually not an ape it's a monkey it's orangutan isn't it orangutan so that's an ape okay I'm not
也是最重要的，实际上不是猿类，它是猴子，它是红毛猩猩，不是吗？红毛猩猩，所以那是一只猿类。好的，我不是
I'm primatologist I think everyone can tell by now so Jenny was an orangutan in London Zoo in the late 1830s. The London Zoo was the world's oldest scientific zoo, founded famously by Sir Stamford Raffles, Tom, the founder of Singapore. And Jenny had arrived from Borneo at the end of 1837.
灵长类动物学家，我想大家现在都能看出来了。所以珍妮（Jenny）是19世纪30年代末伦敦动物园的一只红毛猩猩。伦敦动物园是世界上最古老的科学动物园，由新加坡的创始人斯坦福·莱佛士爵士（Sir Stamford Raffles）著名地创立，汤姆。珍妮是1837年底从婆罗洲抵达的。
A sailor called Mr. Moss sold her for £150. She was probably three years old and she was put in a... All the animals in those days were kept indoors. So she was kept in a heated giraffe's house. She wore human clothing
一个叫莫斯先生（Mr. Moss）的水手以150英镑的价格卖掉了她。她可能三岁大，她被放在一个……那时候所有的动物都养在室内。所以她被养在一个加热的长颈鹿房里。她穿着人类的衣服，
and she drank tea. So very Corporal Jackie behaviour. And in March 1838, the 28th of March, she has a very well-known visitor. And it's the same person that you began this podcast with, Tom. So we're bookending it. Beautifully constructed episode.
喝茶。所以是非常“杰基下士”的行为。在1838年3月，3月28日，她有一位非常著名的访客。这就是你开始这个播客时提到的同一个人，汤姆。所以我们正在为它画上句号。构思精美的剧集。
It is Charles Darwin. So Charles Darwin, he's come back from the Beagle expedition two years earlier, and he's been writing in his notebooks thoughts about evolution, about the possible links between humanity and other primates for about 12 months or so. And he writes to his sister about this first encounter with Jenny. He describes her in human terms. So the keeper offers her an apple. She threw herself on her back, kicked and cried like a naughty child. She looked very sulky. The keeper says, Jenny, if you stop bawling and being a good girl, I'll give you the apple.win says she certainly understood every word of this and like a child she had great work to
它是查尔斯·达尔文（Charles Darwin）。所以查尔斯·达尔文，他在两年前从“小猎犬号”（Beagle）探险回来，他在笔记本里写下关于进化的想法，关于人类和其他灵长类动物之间可能的联系，大约写了12个月左右。他写信给他的妹妹，讲述了这次与珍妮的第一次相遇。他用人类的术语描述她。所以饲养员给她一个苹果。她把自己扔在背上，踢着，像个淘气的孩子一样哭。她看起来很阴沉。饲养员说：“珍妮，如果你停止嚎叫，做一个好女孩，我就给你苹果。”达尔文说她肯定理解了这一切，像个孩子一样，她费了很大劲才
stop whining she at last succeeded and then got the apple now orangutans at that point are pretty unknown to europeans they have been a mystery about at 1600s it was a dutch doctor called jacobus bontius who went to java and about orangutans, the wild man of the woods, you know, that kind of stuff. And naturalists had often said, gosh, they are very similar to humans. You know, they've been really unsettled by them, actually. So Linnaeus, when he did his classification, he had put orangutans and other apes in the same genus as humans. Rousseau, not a friend of the rest of history, I would say, Rousseau, he said, could they be a race of genuinely wild men?
停止呜咽，她终于成功了，然后得到了苹果。现在，红毛猩猩在当时对欧洲人来说是相当未知的。关于1600年代，有一个叫雅各布斯·邦蒂乌斯（Jacobus Bontius）的荷兰医生去了爪哇，关于红毛猩猩，“森林里的野人”，你知道，那种东西。博物学家经常说，天哪，它们和人类非常相似。你知道，他们实际上被它们弄得很不安。所以林奈（Linnaeus）在进行分类时，他把红毛猩猩和其他猿类放在了与人类相同的属中。卢梭（Rousseau），我想说，不是《剩下的就是历史》的朋友，卢梭，他说，它们会不会是真正野人的一种？
In other words, are they basically human? Jean-Baptiste Lamarck, kind of pioneer of evolutionary thinking in some ways, he said, could they be the ancestors of humans? Are these our ancestors who have somehow been preserved? And all of these ideas are clearly knocking around Darwin's brain. And he comes back. He keeps coming back. That's the fascinating thing to the zoo, to look at Jenny. We know from his notebooks, he says, he describes her always as a child. And he says, she can do things like groom herself. She can tools he's really struck by her emotions so he's convinced that she's jealous he says she will make peevish noises if she sees other people getting attention she shook the cage and knocked
换句话说，它们基本上是人类吗？让-巴蒂斯特·拉马克，在某些方面算是进化思想的先驱，他曾说，它们会不会是人类的祖先？这些难道是被某种方式保存下来的我们的祖先吗？所有这些想法显然都在达尔文的脑海中盘旋。他回来后，一次又一次地回到动物园去看珍妮。我们从他的笔记中得知，他总是把她描述成一个孩子。他说，她能做一些事情，比如给自己梳理毛发。她能使用工具，她的情绪让他印象深刻，所以他确信她会嫉妒。他说，如果她看到别人受到关注，她会发出烦躁的声音，她摇晃笼子，撞击
her head against the door because she could not get out jealous of attention to other and then the thing that is most struck by they give her a, or he gives her a mirror. And he says, she was astonished beyond measure looking in this mirror. And Darwin was convinced that she recognized herself. She stuck out her lips like kissing to the glass. She put her hand over the glass. She rubbed it. She put her body in different kinds of positions, admiring herself in the glass. All of this is massively playing on his mind. He's got multiple notebooks, and this is one called Notebook C, and he writes in this after visiting Jenny. Let man visit orangutan in domestication,
她的头撞在门上，因为她出不去，嫉妒别人受到的关注。然后最让他震惊的是，他们给了她一面镜子，或者说他给了她一面镜子。他说，她看着镜子里的自己，惊讶得无以复加。达尔文确信她认出了自己。她像亲吻一样把嘴唇贴在玻璃上。她把手放在玻璃上。她摩擦玻璃。她摆出各种姿势，在镜子里欣赏自己。所有这些都在他的脑海中产生了巨大的影响。他有多个笔记本，这是其中一个叫C的笔记本，他在参观完珍妮后写道：让人类去看看被驯养的红毛猩猩，
hear expressive wine, see its intelligence when spoken to, as if it understands every word said, see its affection, see its passion and rage, sulkiness and very actions of despair, and then let man boast of his proud preeminence. Man in his arrogance thinks himself a great work, worthy of the interposition of a deity, more humble and I believe true to consider him created from animals. There you go.
听听它那富有表现力的呜咽声，看看它在被说话时表现出的智慧，仿佛它听懂了每一个字，看看它的深情，看看它的激情和愤怒、阴郁以及绝望的举动，然后让人类去吹嘘他们那引以为傲的卓越地位吧。人类在傲慢中自认为是伟大的杰作，值得神灵的干预，而我认为更谦卑、更真实的做法是承认人类是由动物创造的。就是这样。
And there you have it. Yeah. So Jenny died from an illness a year later, 1839, and was replaced, the cynicism of zoos was replaced by another orangutan called Jenny, who wasn't visited by Darwin, but was visited by Queen Victoria. But that last point that Darwin makes,
就是这样。是的。所以珍妮一年后，即1839年因病去世了，并被取代了。动物园的愤世嫉俗之处在于，她被另一只也叫珍妮的红毛猩猩取代了，那只猩猩没有受到达尔文的探访，但受到了维多利亚女王的探访。但达尔文提出的最后一点，
that's obviously the real fascination, isn't it? Yeah. That we see ourselves looking back at us. Yeah. It's a brilliant way of contextualizing our own kind of boastful narcissism if you've ever been to a zoo i actually i'm transfixed by watching gorillas and chimps and all that kind of thing because precisely for that reason because they are so human or rather we are so ape-like well we are apes yeah yeah exactly exactly well brilliant domin. Thanks very much.
那显然才是真正的魅力所在，不是吗？是的。我们看到自己回望着我们。是的。这是一种绝妙的方式，将我们那种自吹自擂的自恋置于背景中。如果你去过动物园，我实际上会被观看大猩猩和黑猩猩之类的东西所吸引，正是因为这个原因，因为它们太像人了，或者更确切地说，我们太像猿了。嗯，我们就是猿。是的，没错，没错。太棒了，多米。非常感谢。
So those are history's top monkeys. Yeah. And apes. Of that there can be no doubt, Tom. We hope you've enjoyed it, and we'll be back next week to look at more history of apes. More apes. But specifically, Homo sapiens. Alright. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman
所以这些就是历史上最顶级的猴子。是的。还有猿。对此毫无疑问，汤姆。我们希望你们喜欢这期节目，下周我们将回来探讨更多关于猿的历史。更多关于猿的内容。但具体来说，是智人。好了。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，
and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment It's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain
我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开幕后，
on entertainment and we tell you how it all works We have just launched our Members Club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access
带你了解娱乐业的运作方式。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前购买
to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。